Heh.
Why you bully me liquid one sooner? Why you bully me?
Look, I figured out how to lift the chair, okay?
Just because I didn't do my hands doesn't mean that I couldn't do my leg.
Mommy's been pinned! No, I'm pinning the fucking chair!
Good morning!
Good evening! Good afternoon sleepyheads!
How are ya?
Hi hi! Momette is here.
I put the little background music on.
Look how cute that is!
That's so peaceful!
Now, there's some forbidden lore that I'm actually gonna message the concept that it's about.
In another life, you looked very similar to the main character in the game
because you were a turnip in another beautiful life that I got you.
And you were still called reflin.
Spelling was a wee bit different, but you were still called my little reflin and you were a
adorable little turnip.
And you look very similar in this game.
And I'm actually gonna contact your concept artist because you look incredibly familiar
in this game.
And I'm like, why does everyone call her mummy?
Because in my Scottish accent, mummy is spelled phonetically as mummy.
I thought we were a radish.
You are, but you look eerily similar to turnip.
So I'm gonna see if the concept artist had that in mind.
Or if it was just by chance.
If it was just by chance, no big deal.
But in either case, both ways you're adorable, but I have to admit you're more
a little bit more arwardable in this.
So now yes, I understand you clicked on the stream and it looked like that.
So I apologise.
I woke up with very bad separation anxiety this morning and I do not feel I have the
vocabulary to present to you my little darlings and my heart rate was a bit above the
what my personal normal threshold is for my heart rate.
So I've had to take my heart medication.
But don't worry, it's not a big deal.
But instead, I thought we would play turnip boy commits tax evasion, which is such a freaking
cute thing.
Is turnip boy a leaked mascot from a gen two or perhaps?
Oh no.
Production takes a very long time.
I'm happy to say no.
Fuck you, turnip boy.
We're here now, mummy.
Get loved, get loved, get loved.
Pop, pop, pop, pop.
But yes, we're going through this game.
Apparently this game takes two hours to play.
Whether or not it's going to take me two hours to play is a whole different.
I don't even know what we're looking at for this gameplay.
All I know is that it's cute and apparently it's accessible to new gamers.
And that's all I need to know.
That's all I need to know.
As long as I can finish it, that's all I need to know.
A turnip girl for gen two.
You guys have far too much faith in me.
Endurance stream.
Tax bill.
You owe a ton of property tax for your greenhouse.
You have until like yesterday to pay it.
Failure to pay will give Mayor Onion the deed to your house.
Total owed 143,753 and plus 50% interest.
Sincerely the government.
Mayor Onion's official seal of approval.
Department of taxation.
Rip up or read what word of red is.
So let's rip it up.
Nice Johnny.
Hi, Riefling.
Oh, I got an achievement for ripping up.
Oh, turnip boy.
You really screwed yourself.
What do you mean what?
You committed tax evasion.
I did not talk.
Uh, yes.
Tax evasion is a real thing.
Anyway, you owe me a lot of money and you obviously have none.
So consider yourself my personal assistant.
First, head over to the bustling barn through Leia Lane.
I'm trying to set up a town hall there.
But there's a bunch of animals I need to take care of.
Oh, you don't talk.
You're non-verbal.
Bring me back a bag of fertilizers, proof or you'll be sleeping with a rotten man.
Is the game volumes too loud, too quiet?
Indentured servitude.
That's illegal.
It is.
Oh my God.
Look at the little chickadees.
Oh, Old Man Lemon's house.
Home of the extremely convenient watering can.
I found a wort.
Use this to grow plants.
Used to be Old Man Lemon's.
I need to talk to him.
Hello chat.
Have you seen me old watering can?
Uh, my eyes aren't what they used to be.
I haven't seen for days.
That watering can means so much to me.
I really hope no one's stolen it.
The only thing I've left for the old lady.
Oh, no.
Can we give it back?
I don't think we can.
Uh, hold on.
Me, me old trackers right in the way of the screen.
Hold on.
Let me, let me just recalibrate.
Let me run that immersion for five things.
The fucking things in the water screen.
Okay, there we go.
Give it back.
It has social anxiety.
Oh my God.
We have a watering can there.
Bravo to use.
Okay.
That's so cute.
Hello.
Hello there.
Just since the weather is lovely.
Just as lovely as that strawberry down the screen.
She's so nice.
Oh, don't get me.
Don't get me.
Thanks for the super chat.
Don't judge me.
I'm enjoying my little watering can game.
Thank you.
619 school.
Am I supposed to say old school?
Or did I literally go 619 school?
619.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh, it's you going.
Oh wait.
It's you saying the dialogue in game.
I'm sorry.
I'm not very.
Hold on.
I got it.
Okay.
She's so lovely.
Say, could you water this plant for me?
I ran out of water and want to give this special flower to that special strawberry.
What?
I found this.
A flower.
A token of affection from the flowers to the strawberry.
A strawberry.
Oh, literally right there.
Hi.
Turnip boy.
Thanks for the flower.
But I don't feel the same.
I'm sorry.
Oh, it's not from you.
Oh, thank the mushrooms.
The florist sent you this way.
How sweet are you?
Do you think you can take this letter over to her from me?
Dear florist.
Thank you for the pretty flower.
Would you like to go on a date?
Some day we can even get married and pay our taxes together like strawberries.
I don't want the cage put on me for tax evasion.
So here's my straw me tax.
I don't want a cage put on me for tax evasion.
So it stays there.
Thank you for the five.
Are you getting a cage put on you either way?
Heartless.
You tore up a love letter.
Wait, because it mentions taxes.
Hi.
I'm a blooper.
You're a turnip.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Are these the bad guys?
Excuse me.
Wait, hold on.
I need another voice other than like Brineal from Skyrim.
A male voice.
Anyone.
Any male voice.
Any region.
Excuse me.
Ragaabao.
Add the lessons.
Please step away from the premises.
This is an IRS operation.
We need to secure the area before you pass.
This is not even a voice.
We've got our eyes on you.
Everyone's becoming French.
That's all I can do.
Right.
We got lemon.
He said it had to grow up to a lane.
Hold on.
Does this tell me what we believe in?
Layers lane is left.
Okay.
We're going to layers lane.
Wait.
Westmore.
Oh my God.
You can fall over.
So I guess this is all my way to single.
Watch out for the snails.
They're vegetarians.
Oh.
Okay.
Hello, Mr. Blueberry.
Bro.
You ain't going to believe this.
Jerry's been crashing at my place for a week
and he hasn't paid a single cent of rent.
We're on good terms, bro.
Trust me.
But I don't speak much snail.
I don't really know what to do about it, bro.
Well, I can't touch them.
I'm a turnip.
I'm literally getting my health yanked off me.
Stony's ink tech.
Snail.
Soil.
Sword.
Patch ahead.
Bring a watering can.
Oh.
You'll never guess what I have.
I can see a person there.
Hello.
Hey, turnip boy.
I've been traveling around the farmland
and exploring the forest around it.
And I found something cool.
Up ahead is a rare plastic sordicus.
If you...
Oh, planticus sordicus.
If you have a second, check it out.
Okay.
You don't have to tell me more.
Oh, it's snake paint.
Hello.
Thursday, launch patch.
Someone please war this boy.
Okay.
Whoa, I found this.
The soil sword.
It's dangerous to grow alone.
Take this.
It's a legend to sell the reference.
Wait.
Oh.
You can only have one item at a time.
Okay.
I'll keep that in mind.
And then if I want to swap, I just...
Okay.
It seems to pause the in-game time
if I do that, let's say.
We getting strapped.
We strapped.
Is that...
Winning for tax evasion.
No, I'm not.
Stop it.
I'm not evading taxes at all.
I'm in...
Cerebritude.
That's different.
Hello.
Oh, heck.
I lost the baby.
I was told the baby said a little carrot.
I sat over him with the stool,
but he escaped my sight.
Maybe the stool needs to sit on me.
Either way, you can keep your eye whole peeled.
What?
I swear that's how the phrase goes.
You've lost a carrot?
How do you lose a carrot?
Oh, I'm not arguing.
I don't know where the baby...
If the baby...
Are you got the baby and saved you?
Open up right now.
What did you give me?
Whoa, I found this rent money.
Jerry was going to pee his rent.
Oh, no.
We slid...
Oh, we...
Bro, why did you kill Jerry?
He was defenseless.
Why?
Oh, wait.
He had his rent money?
Oh, cool beans, man.
Mm-mm.
Bro, since he's dead,
take his check for the remainder.
I need that cash.
Quarter of that in tax.
I hate tax.
How could you kill him?
Oh, sorry.
I just walloped into that.
I've just hurt myself.
Oopsie.
Reefling you, burp!
You can burp!
You can burp, darling!
10 out of 10 game, my Reefling can burp.
You're so lore-accurate.
Okay, now we go this way
because we have access, almost.
Oh, there's like little nickel cat farm.
Mummy's the greatest murderer.
Layer lane.
Oh, you're a carrot.
Oh, no, you're not.
You're something else.
You'll need a haircut, desperately.
Oh, but who's the great Edgar?
Best father and all of Edgy Vinn are my kidney.
A famous client of mine wants me,
the great Edgar, to dye their hair.
But alas, I do not have the dye to do it.
Obviously, this client is higher priority
than your dumb hair.
I urge you to come back another day.
See what I think about your property.
I take that.
That's what I think about your property.
You'd reshape the business.
Oh, my God.
Wait, this is a food show.
We can go on a date.
Welcome to Wee Sanguit, home of the tier three sub.
Is that supposed to be a Twitch Reference?
Can I take your order?
Oh, you don't want anything of yours.
Mm-mm.
Business has been really slow.
I wish I could get someone famous to eat our subways.
So, say, a live stream or something.
Wait, what?
This is a Twitch Reference.
What the fuck?
That would really bring up into the business.
Is that supposed to be if someone plays this game live,
then the chat starts gifting stuff?
Oh, there's a bin.
Or do I say, have you done your taxes?
Save 3%?
No!
How dare you?
I'm not doing my taxes.
Strongly can have my footlong sub.
It's not a footlong.
You know what?
It's a footlong.
Three of these.
How many inches is a footlong?
I'm curious.
Help wanted.
Hiring exterminators to get rid of unwanted livestock.
What a cute little game.
Sorry, this game is absolutely perfect.
Ah, I'm loving it so far.
Are you okay if I have a quick tea break?
12 inches.
Fuck it, hell.
12 inches is a footlong?
Who the fuck's walking around with 12 inches?
Subgamer, I'm...
Wait, is this Slay Queen?
That would be an eager voice.
How does the California voice again?
Number one.
Subgamer, I'm Mayor Unus's assistant.
But you've called me by my gamer tag, Slay Queen32.
Huh?
Wait, I'm the best for...
Wait, what the fuck?
What's the vocal fry in California go like again?
I swear, Shibi did a fantastic emanation.
Emination?
Intimidation.
Valley girl.
What is a valley girl?
Oh my god, why can't I think of what a valley girl sounds like?
Holy shit.
Valley girl.
Um, I'm the best varculent player in Bendyville.
I want to tell you to check out my streams
that I haven't been able to go live since the pigs in here
make so much noise.
Oh, you want to get into the bustling barn?
Well, I have some bad news for you.
Access is exclusive to my true fans,
so give me a tear thingy sub.
It wouldn't be fair to let you go in for free.
Be sure to like and subscribe, though.
What the fuck are you on about?
Mental mental.
Yeah, I'm not subscribing to your ass.
What the fuck?
Unless I get a tax rebate.
Right.
Interact.
Kido, this is an active construction site.
Stop, no, don't gift memberships
because the game is prompting it.
Thank you, boy, for the gifted membership.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We're not doing this.
Thank you, D-Man0302 for the gifted memberships.
Let me in.
Why am I no one?
I'm on break.
Brother, I work here.
See the documents to prove it real.
They're clearly...
Rip it up.
Where does it mention tax?
I don't know.
It's getting ripped up.
You tore up someone's 10.99.
Oh, I see it.
I see the wee trophy.
Hello.
Trophy, reward the player so they stay engaged.
You obtained a chunk of gold that makes you feel good.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, why is this game so good?
Hey, hello, turnip over here.
I have short-term memory loss.
I'm just trying to get a veggie bill.
Please tell me where I am.
Oh, thank you.
I now know where I am.
I never said anything.
Pay taxes, of course, right.
Wait, does anyone go this way?
Trust me, you do not want to go down this alleyway.
There's some shady stuff down there.
Trust me, boy.
Right, well, no.
Oh, I literally can't go down.
Right, something's supposed to happen.
Hello.
Oh, hi there.
Are you looking to purchase some real estate?
Oh, turnip boy, I'm sorry about that.
I hope you get your greenhouse back soon.
I've been so busy lately.
Mayor Onion has been trying to raise property tax.
Mm-hmm.
It's been really hard to find new clients.
Yeah, I imagine so.
Oh, imagine so.
Right, hold on.
Let me drink my tea,
because it's going to get absolutely cold.
That shady stuff, my favorite.
Game is honestly pretty good and meta, is it?
I had no idea what to expect,
but from the opening alone, I'm happy.
So if I get filtered by a boss fight, that's on me,
because this is really good.
Wow.
Respect to the gifters.
Literally role-playing, how dare you.
Thank you again to the gifters.
I appreciate that.
Oh my God, you're asleep on screen,
because you're so sleepy.
Let me finish my tea.
No, the boss fights are pretty simple.
You're going to love this.
Oh, fuck yeah, this is my kind of game.
I'm about to recommend this game to all the girls.
I don't know if that's it.
I have like a little chat.
For the girls, and I put in two-hour games,
and I'm like, hey, here's a little game
that only took me two hours to only take you two hours.
Sleeping on the job, turnip boy.
Look, he had a big long night with me.
I didn't hear a refund, huh?
Oh yeah, I got some motherfucking work done.
I'm so happy.
The VTuber Establishment Program is now up.
You can apply for it if you have an Establishment Program channel.
Just because you apply doesn't mean you get in,
but fucking, you never know.
Just apply.
I have fun.
Go for it.
I managed to edit AC's role play.
I managed to subtitle it up for her.
So that's out right now.
If you're in the business for ASMR,
AC has an ASMR role play out right now.
She was streaming earlier.
I don't know if she's finished.
Hi, Trani.
Hi, Evelyn.
Merci has sent me a role play.
I need to record me cutting my hair.
I didn't do it yet, but I'm going to do it tonight.
And I am also editing the side collab.
I finally got to it in per side.
I felt so bad.
I had to send her a message,
and I was like,
you've accidentally sent me your voiceline sped up,
because I'm whispering and I'm really soft,
and I'm like, are you sure we should be doing this?
And then Said comes on and she's like,
yeah, I think it's literally really good.
I just did it in the middle of the day.
So I'm like, I'm so sorry Said.
You've accidentally sped up the voicelines
underneath the original, if you can.
So when she's ready, then that'll be done.
It was a cute mistake.
She's like, I don't know how I even managed that.
And I'm like, honestly, don't worry.
It happens all the time.
Because I was really slow.
And then she's like,
and I'm like, okay, I'm so sorry Said.
I'm going to have to ask you to redo that.
Or resend me the original.
And I made a start on the baby pink viola collab.
Yes, I know it's supposed to be a surprise,
but at this point,
bro, it's taken me so long to do any of the surprises.
I'm hoping Mercy, Said, and baby pink are all done tonight.
Now, baby pink is the way on hiatus right now.
She is going for a break,
her first time breaking a couple of years,
which I'm really happy about.
Her prove proper wasn't very well,
but the collab goes on baby pink's channel.
The artwork has been animated and all that.
They finally came to it took quite a while.
And then after that is peaches,
dream of peaches.
But don't be surprised if I'm going to try and arrange a collab.
This is just straight up what I plan to do.
I'm going to see if I can arrange a collab between myself,
since it's their dream of peaches or peaches VTuber.
And baby pink, it'll be all four of us together,
which I think will be very nice.
I'm going to see if I can arrange that, get that done.
I've got a few more collabs on the way.
I'm trying to be quite social this month.
And then after that,
I'm literally just diving straight into being solo dolo.
I absolutely adore arranging collabs,
but I don't feel as uncomfortable with them anymore.
I felt very uncomfortable with them in another life,
but this time it feels, for things feel different for me.
In terms of yo, what peaches tell ya?
Well, peaches is like, you should say,
peaches was such a supporter of Vila when it first popped up.
She was like so nice.
I didn't expect her to like even give a rat's arse about it.
And she was like screaming from the rooftops about it.
She was like interacting and under all the posts.
And she's like so polite to the girls and that.
Peaches is super, oh, she was just lovely.
So yeah, peaches and baby pink,
let me call in a favor with them.
And I'm really thankful for the opportunity
that they provided for the girls.
Yo, you will be able to reap the rewards.
Again, it's free access content.
It's not anything.
Peaches has short feature and she be saying,
but yeah, that's amazing.
I've not seen that on these click-ups.
But yeah, we, we've got fun things in the works.
But thank you for like our conversation yesterday.
Like just letting me talk about kind of like what work I have to do.
Because it helps me compartmentalize
and it made me realize that if I work every single day this week,
I will have cleared my entire work schedule.
I need to stop being afraid of working,
installing and just, just do it.
Because unironically at the rate I'm going,
I will be done in three days if I keep up the stamina.
I'm not even kidding, three days and I'm done
and I can do all the fun.
Like literally I have a piece of paper right here
with all these ideas.
I've got, if I can even read them.
I've got a Twitter audio that ends in dumb loss for you.
I've got, I'll let you use a mirror on me
because I did a Baltrow wager.
I've got hypnotizing you to like pineapple pizza.
Girlfriend munches on your crusty socks ASMR.
Like all these fun goofy things we came up together.
I can do that once I have cleared my schedule.
Like, like it's happening.
It's hot.
Right, don't say no.
I know that other one was pretty gross.
But it's like, it's happening.
Don't let your dreams, literally all the memes are coming back.
All the fun stuff I want to do is coming back.
The girls that want to engage in YouTube role plays,
like they've got my full support.
Like Aisie is, she's going full steam ahead.
She's so excited to do it.
And yeah, she did fantastic in that role play.
And I'm not being funny, right?
So I was the one that edited Aisie's role play.
Like I wrote the script for her and that just to,
it was just a start to get her started type thing.
And then I think she's going to do stuff off the top of her head.
So obviously I wrote the end of it.
And I have to admit, you can hear her voice perk up
because in the script, I wrote, like Goodnight kisses you.
I love you, Dada.
I wrote that in the script for her to say,
and you can hear the infliction in her voice
at the end of that role play go up because she goes,
I love you, Dada.
And I thought that was a cute little thing,
like a little detail, a little cherry on top of that role play.
I thought it was very sweet.
Not the pineapple pizza, the crusty sock is fine though, you.
The crusty, wait, I just clogged that.
The pineapple pizza is the wrong one,
but the crusty sock role play where I'm munching on it.
It's fine. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I finished me tea.
I'm going to have some water as well
and you keep my hydration up.
Hey, since the schedule's changed,
how about you finish blanks?
You know what?
How about I put it in a cage right now?
How about that?
How about I put it in a cage and I swallow the key?
And the, no, no, we're not good with it.
Do you need some fans to donate some pre-crusted socks?
I wonder if that would make the noise more authentic.
I was just going to chew on some hard stuff.
I don't know if maybe I should do gag in ASMR.
Like I should purposely gag while I do it.
So I'm like, speaking of gagging.
Okay, indirect.
Oh, pardon me.
Right, what would an orange sound like?
The real estate agent sold me the studio apartment.
It's smaller, the most, the more expensive.
I'm hoping the alleyway scenery pumps me full of creative juices.
Oh, yeah.
Right, we've spoken to everyone in this area.
Yeah, this is like locked off.
This place is off limits.
Come back later when you beat the game.
Orders from the boss.
I don't know what it means either.
That's hilarious.
So there's post-game content.
Right, let's go back into town
because I clearly missed something.
Oh, sorry.
I made you twat, you mean thing.
I'll get the key back.
Uh, grim, I guess this is too early.
Interact.
What do you want, kids?
Listen, I'm getting ready to rob this.
Rob the rotten, I need complete focus.
And you seem like the annoying type.
Get out of my sight, kid.
How do you?
Right, so weapons wood with east.
We can't go down.
We've already, maybe we were to help the carrot person.
Oh, I keep doing that.
Sorry.
I keep rolling into the enemy.
I've slayed the beast.
Right, we're going to see if we can find the carrot over here
because I think that's what we're supposed to do.
But maybe if we slay all the enemies, we find the carrot.
Is there any up here?
Oh, wait, no.
What?
Oops, I didn't even saw this.
What's up, dude?
Got any spray paint?
Yeah, I'm itching to vandalize some public property, you feel?
Wait.
But that's illegal.
You can't do that.
I guess I don't get any money, like in-game currency.
I might actually pay my taxes first or...
Okay, these keep respawning.
So I don't think that's what we're supposed to do, carrot.
I like your burps.
Oh, you just wait until the next emmy short comes out.
Someone has been very dedicated to clipping
emmy's burps in particular.
So I was just going to put a compilation together a little bit.
What?
I swear that's...
I don't know where the baby is.
I don't know if I'm supposed to actually help.
Is the baby in here and I need to jump in here?
No, I can't see if he is.
Least arranged pimple.
Base pimple, keep it up.
Big bro, literally.
Big bro knows what he wants.
Bruh.
Oh my god, right.
So I've posted emmy's short on Reddit
about her being really informative as a content creator.
Sorry, I can't for the life of me figure out what I'm supposed to do right now.
I feel like I'm missing something.
You really screwed yourself over.
Right, go head over to the bustling barn.
Okay, right.
There must be something at the barn that I missed.
And it was like a really informative thing about what AvTuber is.
Because some people think that we're loot tubers,
but there's a differentiation.
AvTuber is like you straight up do popcorn and we do audio popcorn.
Okay, I definitely missed something.
It must be in here.
Did she just let me go?
Did I need to like break her PC tail?
Did I need to water her?
Oh wait, did she want this?
No.
I'm gonna have to water her.
I'll show her you in love.
Yeah, you like that.
And fuck it, I'll break your PC while I'm on it.
I'm definitely missing something.
Sorry, the brain cells.
You got to pay with your sub.
You got to pay for a sandwich.
Hi.
I would like food, please.
Welcome to waste sandwich home of the...
Oh, it's you again.
Wait, this is like Queen 30 tier...
32 wants a tier three sub?
Here, it's on the house.
Just make sure she eats it on stream so I can get that cloud.
Okay.
Sorry, this game is like a 10 out of 10.
It's so fucking cute.
And it's got all these things.
Oh god, I've forgotten how to do the AliExon.
The California.
California.
Oh my god.
I'll turn it, boy.
Thank you for the tier three sub.
As a tier three sub, you gain access to the bustling burn.
As well as my autograph.
Here you go.
Now, if only someone would do something about all those piggies making noises.
I'm just being able to actually stream.
Thank you for the tier sub.
Be sure to pay your taxes next time.
Like fuck I will.
Fuck you, bitch.
What are you?
Warning, active bombsite.
Water twice.
Hello, bomba?
There's fucking nuclear bombs in this game.
Legalized nuclear bombs.
Oh my god, that's so good.
Thank you for the tier three sub.
Fuck you!
Okay, if I was from California, that's how I would do it.
Okay, we're clearing out the barn so she can stream.
Oh, we have boots.
Whoa, I found this.
Boom boots.
Use these to kick boom blooms.
Run into them to send them flying.
Did I need to actually equip one?
It doesn't look like it.
Okay, what's this?
Hello, boom.
Oh wait, no, sorry.
Bravo, bravo.
Boom!
Oh my god, that's such a cool mechanic.
Boom, boom.
Oh wait, why did I do that?
Oh, all right, let's try that again.
Hold on, hold on.
That is...
I don't know.
Blah!
Boom.
Uh, owl.
Okay, there we go.
Bees make hun.
Uh, Racy, thank goodness you're not from California.
What are you talking about?
You don't like my vocal fry.
Sorry, I'm so sorry.
I don't mean I like that.
A little bit.
A little bit, I mean, but...
You don't like my vocal fry?
How did you tax my William?
Jo, I'm fucked your taxes!
Sick of them!
Okay, Mayor, Offices, Onion, okay.
Um, is that what I was supposed to do?
Wow.
Sorry, the controls are a bit...
Not what you expect them to be.
Wait, is that explorative reason?
Oh, a key!
Okay, okay, hello.
Okay, um, now back to the warren can.
And then kick them down.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I just want to keep being on the sword in case like...
Fuck you, beach!
Yickens!
I don't know if I'm supposed to kill the yickens.
I don't know, that seemed to rather mean...
I'm gonna just leave the chickens.
I think they're okay.
Oh my god!
Collateral damage on Ironically, sorry!
Didn't mean it.
Didn't mean it!
Collateral damage.
Let's let go!
Right, I've got one great...
Turnip boy is a vegetable of focus, commitment,
sheer will, something you know very little about.
I once saw him kill three snails in a barn
with a soil sword, an FKN soil sword.
Fucking soil sword, man!
Thank you, reluctantly seen for the...
The tip, fuck!
Thanks for your tip.
Um, hello, mummy.
He's to...
He's to root vegetable at and not filling a guvernant.
Imposed levees.
Boss fight!
King pay!
Uh, what?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Let's start watering shit.
I don't know what I'm doing, but I'm kicking him.
Nope, okay.
Hold on, you're too quick for my buddy.
Bunk!
Okay, let's try that again.
And then bunk.
Oh my God!
Not the game mode actually being accessible.
If the...
Oh my God, 10 out of 10 game.
If these are the boss fights, 10 out of 10 game.
You mean games that are actually fucking nice?
What?
Is that bacon?
Oh no, he turned into crispy bacon.
I would like to take that.
Whoa, you found a heart fruit.
This fruit gives you another heart.
Nifty!
Oh my God!
First try, zero death.
Bro, I'm sorry.
If the game's like this, this is an instant 10 out of 10.
Well, you found the fertilizer.
Makes things grow like crazy.
Why does he want that?
I don't know, let's break some stuff.
It seems that those who consume
fertilizer display mysterious properties,
such as rapid growths.
Yeah!
Did you know that some fertilizer,
some...
What is it?
It's not pesticides, some cropicides?
The ones that kill the crops.
Actually, instead of poisoning the plant,
they make the plant grow so rapidly
it can't sustain itself.
And the plant basically kills itself by accident.
Can you stream now?
Oh my God, thank you.
Some peace and quiet.
Turn it, boys.
Get this, thank you.
However, you have personally crowned
you as slay king, thank you.
Oh, I actually did get crowned.
Aw.
Heads up, you can view and equip
all the hats in the pause menu.
Oh my God, refling, you have a crown!
Cause you're my king!
Okay, I'mma put my sword on
cause I don't trust myself to not be out
without a sword.
Fertiliser is this world's steroids fan pretty much.
Did we just get hooked up with an arrow?
I thought so.
You're a kingling!
Keep your head up, kingling.
One...
Wait.
I'm glad those animals are at the picture.
This fertilizer will come in handy too.
All right, so your next task with my assistant
is to get me a four pronged spear.
In ancient times, it was known as a fork.
Assistants don't ask questions.
Word on the grapevine
is that there's one in the forsaken farmhouse
that's supposedly south of here.
I've heard horror stories
about a bunch of moldy sweets in that place.
You're in no place to complain.
Go and get my fork.
Okay.
Geez.
Right.
Okay, yeah.
So these are moved out of the way.
So this is definitely correct direction.
Hello.
What do you see?
You like to learn new dances
and post them on flip-flop.
Oh my god, this game's so cute.
Sometimes I'll even do karaoke.
Oh, karaoke.
Did I say karate or karaoke?
Hi there.
I'm a teacher from a nearby patch.
Nice to meet you.
I would love to stop and talk
but I have to attend to my class.
We're on a field trip.
This place is pretty cool.
There is an interesting cave.
I want to have the kids check out later.
I bet you were doing a rescue mission.
Oh, give me that manual.
I want to rip it up.
Okay, so the pupper.
All tangerine dogs will cease to exist
when the game is being.
Whatever that means.
So there is a ton of post game content.
That's the second post game content.
Wallop.
I'm walloping everywhere.
I must go.
Hope you enjoy evading those dine taxes.
Thank you.
I must go.
Hope you enjoy evading those dine taxes.
Thank you, Lord of Storms,
to the Super Chat.
I appreciate it.
Fertilizer.
Hardly even know her.
Oh, come on.
Stand aboard.
Don't be shy on me now.
Hold on.
Let me get up.
It's just shy.
Hold on.
Fertilizer.
Hardly even know her.
Thank you.
I don't know why I'm so shy there.
Yeah, we live pretty far down from town.
It's scary to go over there.
So we just vibe here.
Just swinging back and forth as one does.
So the carrots don't want to move.
I can't get into the house.
I bet the view from that deck would be amazing.
Too bad the stairs are broken.
Maybe we could use a stool.
Wait, is that a JoJo reference?
Oh, come on.
Come on.
What is that?
Was that a Rero?
Am I supposed to read that Rero, Rero, Rero, Rero, Rero, Rero, Rero?
Like, come on.
Okay, come on.
Sorry.
This game is so good.
I don't care.
Do you like my specifically placed collection?
They're totally not keeping you in the level or anything.
That would be work.
Sorry.
I love games that acknowledge how frustrating that is.
Okay, you found this was carrot baby.
The babysitter must be looking for it, right?
Let's go give the carrot back to the babysitter or I'm going to forgo.
Oh, wait, can I?
I just saw something I couldn't.
Child acquired.
I literally have a child in my inventory.
Stop it.
You, you're getting ripped up.
12.3% tax.
Not on my watch.
Imagine if I accidentally got 100% collection.
Okay, I'm going to go back to the babysitter
because I'm going to forget that I even have this child on hand.
So, well, it's got dark.
Literally.
Wait.
Oh my God.
It's a dumpster baby.
I was like, what do you mean it just got dark?
But you're right.
It's a dumpster baby.
Oh, I never put you in the dumpster refund.
Um, no.
Oh my God.
Sorry.
I need to invest in the game.
This dev team.
You found him.
Thank you so much.
Take my soul.
He can't get away this time if he's on my head.
Oh, right.
Okay.
That's literally what we were supposed to do.
We were supposed to backtrack.
Okay.
We have a still.
So now we can go on the deck.
You wouldn't mind me being on your deck, right?
You know, a bit of height advantage.
Sorry.
It's too easy.
Stop it.
I need to look in the dev team of this game.
Sorry.
This is just absolutely fantastic.
Thoroughly enjoying this.
This is a very gamer, accessible, very friendly,
very, um, kawaii desune.
It's getting all the points.
All the points.
You can wax my deck.
You want me to wax it?
I mean, I could if you...
Dear Joe, mom and dad grounded me for breaking the front window.
But Matt was the one who did it.
I ain't no snitch, but I wish he'd bested her.
What is these funky tunes?
Oh my God.
Ow!
Why is it farting at me?
Stop it!
Stop farting at me.
Right now.
Thank you for burping, Lucy.
What's this?
A doctor's mask.
Stay six feet away, right?
What does that do?
I don't know.
You're in a haunted house anyway.
Bomba.
Okay.
New mechanics.
Hmm.
There's definitely something...
Dear Joe, I went to Matt's baseball game today.
I was so weird since everyone was wearing masks.
And we set fire from all the other problems.
Matt hit a ton of home runs though.
However, there's definitely something new.
I don't know.
Definitely something I'm supposed to do.
And it's not clicking what I'm supposed to do.
You push it into the hole once you get an item.
Oh, but I will continue to explore.
Oh, I don't like it.
I don't like sorry that I don't like things that touch me.
Like that's really far away.
That's cheating.
That wasn't very pleasant.
Please don't do that again.
I didn't actually expect to get a little bit
scared in this game.
Sorry.
I know I'm a big baby, but I don't like things that grab
and that have long arms.
Hello.
Ho, ho, ye horses there partner.
Did you really just destroy our 40 vocations?
Well, you better be willing to help out to cover the costs.
I'm a little bit in debt.
I'm a bit short on change.
Go over yonder to the mission board.
Some folks got some work that needs to be done.
Now don't look so down.
It's the least you can do.
Take this key.
You should be able to explore the farmhouse some more
and get some work done.
Now just be careful.
There's rotten food.
If you wanted to be the real doll,
you could start up that generator.
And does these actually have missions?
Supplies needed.
We need bandages and pills.
We need an archery.
Okay.
Oh my God.
It literally goes okay.
Sorry.
I really don't like that.
I don't like that.
Please don't do that again.
Do you understand?
Okay.
We got medicine.
The chair of proof the cap.
Oh my God.
That's our candy handle things that do that to me.
All right.
We need one more thing and then we're okay.
Please.
No more grabbing things.
I will cry.
Oh my God.
You there.
Yeah.
You turnip head.
Don't be alarmed.
I too can hold weapons with no hands.
That's how I know you have mafia blood.
Are you related to Don Ternopachino?
If you are, you're lucky I'm in this jar.
If I weren't, you'd be sleeping with a rhyme.
That mobster family decided to step on our turf.
Who do they think they are?
Holding their meetings in that stupid greenhouse.
What?
Okay.
She's lost her babies.
Well, hello there, hot stuff.
Hm?
Those leaves on top of your hut are so blah.
Say, cutie, could you pick up some medicinal supplies for me?
I'll eat bandages, medicine, and a mouse.
Think you can handle it?
Uh, yeah.
Can I have the key though?
Can I have the key?
You know, give key?
It was only two seconds.
I turned away for two seconds and my baby sister wandered off.
I'm supposed to be the adult here.
After the rot took her parents.
I've been taking care of the family.
Now my little sister is gone.
Oh wait, you'll help?
Thank you so much.
A place for you for the cupcake monsters.
Really, like, don't you?
Don't you?
Right, well, if you give me a fucking key then...
I have a secret stash of brownies hidden in the icebox.
Max keeps eating them and then once we can't find them...
Give me them!
Hello there, sunny Jim.
I thought that the newcomer might be my son,
but there's a new face.
It's definitely a sight for sore eyes.
I don't think I'll ever be able to leave this icebox,
but I hope someday I get to see my son again.
Ah, right.
So no one's given me a key?
Every time.
Right, I know he's in here.
Stop it.
Fuck off, you're bad.
How or what am I supposed to do?
Have I?
So no one's given me a key?
Oh.
Dumbass.
Monk.
Okay.
Toilet sound.
Oh.
Wait, what?
That didn't make it a watermelon?
Okay, there you go.
Okay, okay, okay.
So we can do the medical supply one.
Got it.
Monk.
And then we take the sword out because that thing's going to be bandaged.
And he's a medical strip.
Okay, we get to talk to the sexy lollipop.
Whoa, hold on a minute.
That's the best code word for something else around these parts.
And no, I'm not having dinner with you.
Stop it.
You're terrifying, honestly.
What is this game?
It's like a cute little thing.
I don't know.
My knight in shining armor.
Oh, thank you, darling.
Here's a key sugar.
Darling, come and see me if you need something.
And he came to me.
I'll shock you.
Don't think I won't.
Right.
Let's get right right.
Time to attack.
Every time you respawn and you give me a heart attack, stop it.
Roleplay is the character when you want me to roleplay as that.
That's funny.
But right, you need to stop because he literally gets free hits in because I can't
he like reach him.
What would the watermelon do?
Oh, gloves.
What?
I found this.
The movement and use these to push move melons.
Wait.
Do you have hands?
Not me.
And he's going to drop that.
And it just drops as a heart.
Oh, there's nothing in particular here.
Okay.
I guess I just teach you the mechanics.
Jojo.
Mom got me some new mittens that look like slices of watermelon at the flea market today.
Oh.
You make a little fart noise.
Fart night more like fart night.
What?
I can do this to avoid the boat.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I always forget you.
I'm going to be honest.
Stop it.
You freak me out so much.
You terrify me.
And push.
And we need key.
We could just bomb it all the way down.
Move what melon?
You don't want me Flynn.
I'm actually coming.
Why am I getting dragged?
I'm just playing a kill of pigs with you.
I do indeed have hands.
I'm going to see what they can do.
My fucking HP.
I lost your baby.
Carly's looking for you.
Okay.
Bruh.
I'm so bad against them.
Oh my God.
I got Zach Dream to sign my gigasword poster.
Why we do?
Don't say gigabit in front of a French person.
I'm literally going to die.
Oh my God.
I think the fuck not.
Draft Dodger.
You tore up the draft letter.
Damn right.
I did.
He's going to buy into that.
Oh my God.
Is that a legend of Zelda?
Monk.
Is that you?
Right.
We have a key down there.
There's a fight.
You need to stop it.
You're giving me a heart attack every time I see you.
Gigabits.
What does gigabit mean?
It means massive Willy.
To say Willy in French, you say bits.
And then to say big giga.
So basically, if you say, oh, I've got gigabit internet.
All they hear is big cock internet.
Ha.
Thank you.
Mushroom.
Thank the mushrooms.
My little sister is all right.
Thank you for getting her back.
Thankfully, you're the key for your troubles.
Thank you.
I too have big cock internet.
Let's look.
Remember.
Popo.
What?
Poo poo pee.
No draft for me.
Real and true.
I like your little burp when you heal up.
Sounds like something.
OK.
Let's see what's behind door number.
Oh, there's a note on the bed.
We deeply regret to inform you that Captain
has been missing in action.
Upon receiving further information,
you'll be advised immediately.
Oh my God.
What?
Missing in action?
Oh, no, that's fine.
We don't want them to be.
Pidders.
Gimli, I'm sorry.
I don't pet you.
I'm sorry.
Oh, Gimli.
What the heck?
She's spinning.
Gimli spinning.
Gimli.
No, stop it, Gimli.
Oh, Gimli.
Wait, wait, hold on.
If I wait, so I need to.
OK, hold on.
I can do this.
Gimli, stop it.
Stop spinning.
You're making me nervous.
No, don't cough up another worm.
I told you to stop eating worms
in the garden and you well may stop.
Did I tell you?
Gimli brought me a cockroach
and I don't know what cockroaches are
because I've never seen them before
and Gimli brought one into the freaking house.
That was nice.
And you know what the worst part was?
She brought it in.
Wait, what's going on?
She brought it in and she ate it right in front of me
and I'm like, you know what?
Thank you for not making me clean up
but at the same time, Gimli, no.
No, we do not eat worms.
Sorry, not worms.
We do not eat freaking.
And we don't bring them into the house either.
They upset me.
OK, they upset me.
OK, you, bonk.
Take that.
Bonk.
Oh my God.
Wait, you can like spam.
Stop.
Wait, this is like such a...
Oh, I can't reach them that way.
That's OK though.
I don't know.
I'll just put the bomb there.
Oh, she almost got me.
Oh, you eat cheekies.
Get you.
Oh my God, I think we've done it.
Oh, no, we've not.
Oh my God, I'm so skinny.
Did you see that?
Did you see those moves?
Sorry, I'm going to have to defeat my little...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Can someone drop a wee heart?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
OK.
Oh, thank you.
Wait, go on then.
You could have gone your own life
without seeing a cockroach, honestly.
Honestly, she brings it in.
Oh, what's this?
What?
I found this lost cat apple.
Cran-cran's little red munchkin.
What a naughty munchkin.
Oh my God, stop.
This game is so fair.
I found a heart for it.
It gives you another bit of heart.
Thank you.
Maybe a little secret note here.
Maybe a secret note down here?
Is that everything in the boss room?
Uh, this is not going to work.
Sorry, this game's already a 10 out of 10.
It's suspended.
Machine go.
Oh, big machine goes.
OK.
Oh, what are you?
You found spray paint.
Oh, I know where to go.
We know where to go next.
Interact.
Oh, we put the light on.
Oh, now the place is all not on.
Well, is it still haunted?
Not haunted, you know?
I remember when.
Hey, eternal boy.
It was nice studying this place,
but I got to go take my notes back to the research lab
in a bit.
Side note, did you see the pickled gang?
Yeah.
There are some tourist gang around these parts.
I'm surprised they haven't enlisted anyone
to try and help them break out yet.
Please do not help them.
Oh, well, good thing you told me that
because I probably...
That looks horrific.
The heck did you freaking say about me,
you little turnip?
I'll have you know I graduated top of my class
in the past of seals.
I've been involved in numerous secret raids on the bar
and I've over 300 confirmed kills.
I'm a trained in guerrilla warfare
and I'm a top sniper in the entire pasta armed forces.
You're nothing to me but another target.
I will wipe you the freak out with my precision.
The likes of which has never been seen before on this earth
mark my freaking words.
You think you could just get away with saying that crap to me
over the grapevine?
Think again, turnip.
As we speak, I am contacting my secret network of spies
across the farmland
and your leaves are being traced right now
so you better prepare yourself from the storm, maggot.
The storm that wipes out the pathetic little thing
you call your life.
You're a freaking dead kid.
I can be anywhere, anytime.
I could kill you in over 700 ways.
And that's just with my bare hands.
Not only am I extensively trained in unarmed combat
but have access to the entire arsenal over the past of corpse
and I will use it to its full extent
to wipe your miserable butt off the face of this continent,
you little crap.
If only you could know what unholy retribution
your little clever comment was about to bring down upon you.
Maybe you would have held your freaking tongue
but you couldn't, you didn't
and now you're paying the price, you dang idiot.
I will crap fury all over you
and you're drowning it.
You're freaking dead, kiddo.
I didn't even say anything, geez.
Darn, too, and you started the generator.
Well, can't stay mad at you after that.
This ain't much but this is what we'll go.
We got a four, the four pronged spear.
Sadly, I have to give it to that onion.
So am I supposed to whack him out or not?
I don't think I want to.
Ah, geez.
I wish I could guard the main door.
It seems like everything cool happens there.
Someone just burst through the door.
That's so cool.
Maybe I'm just not good enough with the guard.
That explains why they have me in the prison.
I feel like a good guard.
I wish they would give me a shot.
Am I actually to help them?
Well, I can't even get them out.
Me and the boys are trying to break out.
I can't even get them out anyway.
So he's on his own.
Once I kick them out, no.
I can't even get them out.
This is mad.
Intrusive parts are winning.
Me like, thank you for telling me not to do that.
Also me, hee hee.
Oh, let me try and get them out.
Probably later, yeah.
I'll come back to the mafia.
Maybe we need to recruit the pickle mafia.
Um.
Maybe post game.
This game is very kitted out for post game.
Lately, it's known about how many fish there are in the pond,
but it seems we can only observe one at a time.
Hello.
Ow, what?
I was going to be nice.
We can shove up your arse, honestly.
What's this way?
Rocks.
Okay, looks like we can destroy rocks at a later point.
Okay, okay.
Okay, we got the, we got the fork.
So we're going to give it to the mayor,
and then we're going to go to the spray paint guy,
which is like left, right, basically.
Or is it right, right?
I think it may be right, right, right.
Here's your fork.
Oh, sorry, just...
Right, four pronged spear will come in handy,
all according to plan.
Anyway, Annie has been telling me about this
goop with strange property over in the forgotten forest.
I want it.
No, you can't eat it.
Go get me some of that goop.
I don't care what you have to do to get it.
Okay, I guess, right, I guess.
That's where the spray paint guy is.
The bonk.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, frickin' dude.
My only thing is, by default,
I would say that X should be the action,
but X is the menu change.
That's why I keep rolling into the snails
thinking I'm whacking them.
But honestly, no, not big deal.
Okay, right, you spray paint, let's go.
Thanks, dude.
Take this.
Come back later if you want to see my work.
I got to get in the zone.
Oh.
So you just give me extra heart.
You don't give me...
Is this the deep four?
Is it the, oh, maybe that hatch.
You know that?
I guess the hatch.
I think it's the hatch.
Shove the fish where?
I am the fish.
Wait a minute, I am the fish.
Okay, I can't go in here.
Can you get me in there?
I think the new method of babysitting is working.
Oh, I feel like the mirror is setting up for something illegal.
It's the mirror, the baddie.
I think the mirror is actually technically the baddie
in that video game that everyone plays.
Starter Valley.
And he told me to go to the forest, didn't he?
Northwest.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, whoops.
I just discovered, I was just trying to enter it.
I waited a month for this update and all I got was this loosey hat.
Oh my, oh my God.
Reefling you with a freaking green hat is adorable.
Oh my God, just cute.
You're so cute.
Come in handy.
Anyway, Annie's been telling me about the strange properties
in the Forgotten Forest.
Was that not in the Forgotten Forest?
North, weapons, woods, right.
Forgotten Forest is somewhere else.
Hold on.
I think it might be below.
It was like blocked off down the yard.
It was blocked off.
Yeah, there, there, like down there.
Surely, copy them.
No, no, the JoJo market, guys, that.
Forgotten Forest is west.
Okay, okay.
I do love a good signpost, honestly.
So I guess this guy's not here.
No, he's still here.
Icicle.
No berries.
Hi.
Hi readers.
Hi snowberries.
Have you watched ACC's Samar yet?
Did you get time to watch it?
Did you like ACC's new ASMR?
Didn't she do fantastic?
I think she did fantastic.
Hello, turnip boy.
Mm-hmm.
Welcome to the Forgotten Forest,
and as I like to call it home.
Hi snowberries.
Hi, I'm Rated.
Thank you for the reader.
AC and hi snowberries.
Please enjoy AC's newest ASMR
if you haven't had a chance to look at it yet.
Because I think AC did amazing in the roleplay.
Okay, okay.
Just because I edited it and put subtitles on it,
AC did an amazing job, okay?
I'm a simp for AC.
What can I say?
Not a ton of folk come over.
Not a ton of folk come over here,
but I've been studying this place
for as long as I can remember.
I've seen some very strange things in these woods.
It might be dangerous,
but there's a ton of clues.
But who could it be?
Meet me off ahead in my research facility.
I can help you with the woofer mirror.
Oh yeah.
You love the scratches,
doesn't she do an amazing job?
I was subtitling it and I was like, oh yeah.
Oh my God, there's like, oh!
The bunnies are absurd.
Sheebie, naughty sheebie.
Spank sheebie.
Bad sheebie.
We are playing the tax evasion game,
and it is the cutest thing ever,
and I'm in love with it.
The sheebie's getting...
Oh, and we take HP damage going into the water,
which kind of looks obvious.
I was literally getting boxed out of my wazoo.
You found Holly's phone.
I changed the password.
Lol, no.
Right, I don't know who Holly is,
but hopefully we'll find...
Sheebie!
Sheebie, naughty sheebie.
Don't do that again.
You're hurting me.
I'm excited about the new ASMR.
I'm going to listen to it before bed.
Yes, it's very cute.
It's very sweet.
And I think you'll enjoy her last little sentence.
It's the most adorable.
I was, right, for any snowberries
that don't want it spoiled,
close your ears for, like, 50 seconds, okay?
Close your little ear holes.
So I wrote the script for AC,
but you can literally hear her voice
perk up right at the very end
when she says her last sentence.
That's all I'm going to say, right?
Okay, you can open your ear holes again.
Hello!
Hi, eternal boy!
Oh, welcome to my research facility.
I've been studying the forest around here
to try and learn more about our path.
Not a ton is known about where we even live.
And came from.
It's insane.
This is great, though.
First in a year, Onion finds my research,
and now he sends a new assistant.
I need to perform some field research for him.
Can you go up north from here?
There's a mural I've been trying to get to,
but I can't figure out how to get past the fence.
I might be an explorer,
but I don't like getting my hands dirty.
I'm like, you dirty, dirty boy.
If I can get there, can you doodle it for me?
Uh, sure.
Right, you're not going to hand me the key?
You're going to hand me the key after, right?
Okay, I'll see you later.
She's watching your notes.
I'm using Onion's funding.
I was able to build a lab in this structure.
What secret does this doop in the forest hold?
It's radioactive?
Reefling skull?
That was a quick...
La, la, la, la, la, la, I can't hear you.
Okay, good, good, good.
Oh, that's Dundoo.
We're safe.
Are you safe?
Right, we're full health, so we don't need to do that.
Get out of here!
I went up, wanted for tax evasion, petty theft,
indecent exposure, simping murder,
disorderly conduct, trespassing,
destruction of property, et cetera.
Turn it, boy, $2 reward caution.
He's armed and dangerous?
No, I'm not.
Stop it.
Stop telling fibbers about me.
I'm a hard-working turnip.
My work...
Oh, gamertip.
Did you know you can water through fences?
Now you're a pro gamer.
Is this teleport?
Oh my God, it's portal!
Right, sheebie, you're getting a spank.
Stop it, sheebie.
Stop being so angry.
I must spank you, sheebie.
Don't think I won't do it.
Bad sheebie.
Bad sheebie, get spanked.
Okay.
I thought it would be at least worth
five dollars.
Not at the rate of fucking...
Are you seeing the clipping program?
Wait, why haven't they put a teleport?
Oh, I...
Je comprende.
Dsol.
And this one?
Wait, no, idiot.
Sorry, you didn't see that.
How embarrassing.
Oh my God.
Okay, we have to do a little bit of thinking.
Okay, I'm going to take the sword out
because I don't trust this.
I'm scared.
No, dear girl.
No, dear girl for gen two.
Back off.
I'm getting my ass kicked right now.
No, dear girl.
Bad.
Don't do that again.
Almost perished.
Sorry, I need a scavenge for health.
Okay, there we go.
We're better.
Oh, I squiddled.
Whoa, I found this.
A mural doodle.
Someone drew a giant...
A mushroom giant.
So handsome.
So cute.
Okay, that's the deer.
Right, the deer doesn't respawn.
We're safe.
Apparently I never subbed to you.
Just want to say A.C. A.S.M.I.R.
Uploaded at the perfect time.
Okay, oh, I'm so glad.
I thought...
Right, so obviously I don't want to stress her out.
You know, she recorded it.
I, you know, did it.
I decided that I would put it up two hours
before she streams.
So for the snowberries that are kind of
just waiting for her to stream,
it would pass the time a bit more.
You can listen into the background
or you can wait for it to be a later
and you can listen to that night type thing.
But especially if you're European
because A.C. streams quite late for Europeans.
Like she goes to sleep
pretty close after the end of streaming
all that jazz.
I had a lot of fun editing that
and she had a lot of fun recording it
as far as I'm aware.
I mean, she sounded like she was having fun.
No, dear girl, just fell to my knees in Walmart.
No, you didn't.
We're not having a fucking,
a fucking four-legged Beecherbird.
Get out of here.
I'm not having a four-legged Beecherbird.
You're dear fucking arses and shit.
Yeah, it was past time working on stuff
and these are made out a bit less than I am.
Yeah, that's the thing.
A.C. is very excited to do more role-play ASMRs,
which is fantastic because,
you know, she's a hard-working bean.
You got it.
I forgot what voice I've given.
I think I've given her like three billion voices
at this point.
Fuck it.
She's Jessie from Pokemon.
You got it.
Great work, my trusty field research assistant.
This is very intriguing.
I've known about the legends of the mushroom giants.
It seems kind of hocus pocus at first,
but I gather that they've been a part of our history
for a very long time.
I'm going to need more information
before I jump to conclusions, though,
but I will jump on that fucking cock of yours.
And that's where you come in.
Take this key and head south.
I've heard there's an ancient turnip patch down that way
that I haven't been able to find.
See what you can gather from the locals there
if you can find it.
You're a very smart and well-behaved boy.
I do love when they follow instructions.
Wow.
Can you give me the key, please?
Well, you didn't give me it.
You're just holding on to it.
Give me the goddamn key.
Okay, let's just take our time to explore.
A few more enemies.
Shabby, stop it.
Stop being annoyed.
Stop it, Shabby.
Damn it.
You're getting spanked.
I thought Stronny has been far in this whole time,
but it was the text.
You thought I was brapping my arse cheeks
for an hour and 14 minutes straight.
A reflin.
You thought I was brapping away.
You're getting an absolute spanking for that one.
Bend over.
I thought I was like proudly brapping away.
You're so done.
You're actually so done.
You're in so much trouble after a comment like that.
Oh, I do like that.
Frostina.
On the note of waiting for your streamer going online,
I finally got around to watch the giveaway, SMR.
All I can say is thank you.
And you liked it?
Oh my god, I had so much fun making it.
I'm so glad you liked it.
It was so freaking fun.
I enjoyed it.
I'm so glad you enjoyed it, Frostina.
Thank you for the tip as well.
I had a lot of fun making it.
I know the concept seems like a shitpost,
but I thoroughly enjoyed doing, like, creating it.
I don't know what the fuck I'm supposed to do right now.
Oh, it's supposed to be.
No way I did that in one.
I'm so smart.
Sorry, but I'm actually so smart.
I'm actually so smart.
Oh my god, I'm so smart.
I have like 100 IQ.
Sorry, I don't know why.
I just do.
So scary though.
I'm getting my weapon out.
I thought it was super wholesome.
Bruh, I'm so excited.
Whoa, I found this.
A turnip.
Where's its face?
Why isn't it moving?
Oh no.
Shibby, stop it.
You scared me.
I didn't see you.
All right, is this like a...
I don't know if I'm supposed to do that later.
I'll come back.
This needs to be some sort of access point here.
Let's just access that.
There's an IQ mummy.
Literally, sorry, this game's a 10 out of 10.
Just like...
Um, no?
What?
Okay, what?
How am I supposed to get any wax in?
Go home.
Stop it.
Oh my god, I'm actually...
Why is it so big?
Why was it so big?
Okay, well, I found this.
A potted petal portal.
Use it to spawn a petal portal.
Okay.
Please no more big deer.
That's what she said.
It is so big for no reason.
Okay, so we can now spawn her.
Well, like this?
Okay.
Right.
Sheebie!
You're scaring me, sheepsters.
Right.
If we need to...
I need to put it here to here to get the water in can.
And kick it to the lift.
Oh my god, I'm so smart.
I'm such a smart girl.
What the fuck?
I'm creaming.
I actually feel like I have some IQ right now.
Did we finish everything I had to do there?
I don't know.
Hi.
Did...
Have we finished?
Oh, Mush, I don't understand.
It's like you, but not aware.
I'm so sorry, Turner.
Boy, these adventures have become a bit more morbid than I anticipated.
We really need to get to the bottom of this.
We need to see how this all connects.
Here's my last key.
Take it and go west.
I feel our answers will lie there.
Right, hold on.
We need to get rid of these in the way.
And then I need to put a portal down.
And then I need to sprinkle some water.
Then I need to come up...
No, shit.
And then I need to do this so I can come back and then open this.
And we'll take my weapon out because I don't trust it.
They found an unsentient Turner.
They're killing me.
Oh no, Refling, you threw up.
Refling, no, you threw up.
It's fine.
I'm live.
It's not pre-recorded.
I promise, Refling.
Don't throw up.
No, don't throw up.
Mommy.
Oh, where?
What am I?
What is this gift into you?
Oh no, my babies are throwing up.
I think I fell.
I crawled out of that goop, but I don't know nothing now.
Goop.
Okay.
What about you?
My head hurts.
There's a lot of noise past me.
Right.
It seems dangerous.
Okay.
I've got my sword.
I think I know what our next boss fight is.
Stag, accrual.
Why is it so big?
Can I spank it?
Fuck you, bitch.
Oh, I can.
Right, we're just going for the spank method.
Sorry, but we're doing...
Oh, sheebies!
Don't get attacked, teamed by sheebies!
I can't.
Okay, okay.
It's fine.
Okay, there's a heart here.
You get back here so I can reach you.
Bad sheevee.
Spank sheevee.
I didn't know I could freaking throw stuff on me.
I'm guessing the bombs are a hell of a lot more effective than this.
I don't really know what we're supposed to do.
Well, there's more sheebies.
Stop!
Oh, my God, I'm getting tagged, teamed.
I'm actually getting shagged.
I think I need to spank it when it comes across,
so it's like all I can do.
Unless I sacrifice HP on purpose.
Yeah, okay, maybe let's not do that.
Nice try, but let's not do that.
Ow!
Are you squidding me right now?
Okay, spank?
No, I missed.
Do a flip on stream or it's prerecorded.
Do a flip on stream if it's prerecorded.
I'm in a boss fight, tiny spany.
What do you mean?
I don't have fucking...
I mean, I think this is like the best I can do.
I just wallop it with my wee sword.
Oh, then when it respawns sheevees, they'll drop me HP.
Yeah, okay, I think that's it.
I'm just gonna wallop it with my sword.
Okay, no, stop.
Stop.
No, don't charge.
I'll be mad.
Not mad.
I'm raging.
Right, stand there and just take it like a good,
good little deer girl for gen four.
Take it like a good little deer girl.
That's right.
Get an absolute spanking you.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm spanking you.
So, I know.
Okay, don't do that.
Ow, she...
Oh my god, sheevees actually really good at this game.
A little burpee.
Right, come here.
I need it to let...
Yeah, okay, stand there and take it like a good little deer.
That's right.
I'm sacrificing my HP to beat you up.
Oh my god, I love this game.
Deer four.
Wait, Stronny didn't flip.
It's so pre-recorded.
Stand.
Because people are gonna believe you.
That's the...
That's the dangerous part.
Fruit heart.
This fruit gives you another heart.
Nifty.
Okay.
Okay, now what?
I guess we done though?
Bold move, first try.
We have seven heart containers.
Oh!
Whoa, I found this green goop.
It feels kind of strange touching this.
Why does Mayor Onion want it?
I don't know.
If it stops me from having to pay taxes,
he can get what he wants.
Because I...
I don't care who the IRS sends.
I am not paying the taxes.
Mummy is pre-recorded.
It's true of it.
Oh, I got a little in a thief.
Now she's radioactive.
Double the horn dog.
Oh, he's on a little...
Why are you being sacrificed?
Oh, sorry.
I must own real estate.
I have leaf.
Please get me real estate, turnip.
What?
I found a form of payment for the real estate agent.
I guess I need to go talk to the real estate agent.
Wow, turnip.
Boy, you're glowing.
No, not in the beautiful way.
More in the concerning way.
It seems like everything around you is coming to life.
Also, the goop has a face?
Is it a veggie or an animal?
It doesn't look like either.
What?
You met a bunch of talking acorns?
I thought acorns were just tree seeds.
The goop, the turnip, the mushroom giant?
Maybe this is the key to our evolution.
Maybe the mushroom giants made this goop to give us life.
I need to prepare a report on our findings to Mayor Onion.
This is groundbreaking information.
Thank you for all your help, turnip boy.
I wanted you to have this.
You're a true field researcher now.
Explorers, huh?
I'm a real field researcher now.
Ah, yeah.
Let's go.
Okay, let's go back to the mayor
because I think we need to talk to the real estate agent now.
Wait, is this the way I came?
No, it kind of is.
I like this reward real true.
Is this the way I came?
Oh, I'm getting a bit confuzzled now, but that's okay.
Okay, yeah, okay.
This is the way to go.
Right, go to the mayor, give him the goop.
Go to the real estate agent.
Give her a leaf, see what happens.
And then he'll claim his little acorn.
Nice joining, hi chat.
Hi, people.
You're currently committing to Activation,
just like you should know.
We're avoiding all responsibilities.
So does Mummy want more goop from this huge mushroom?
Oh my God, that's so good.
Wait, it's only trying to make me attach to the avocado.
What, you want to run an avocado?
It'll give you the good stuff.
Oh yes, it's all coming together.
FYI, glowing isn't covered in your health insurance.
It's weird though.
It feels like you're creating life around you.
Next, we need a contraption
that your pea-sized brain couldn't even comprehend.
It's a machine that shoots a red laser.
It's some high-tech stuff.
It's called a laser pointer for short.
There's a strange hatch in weapons,
which I feel like you could find one in there.
Yeah.
I sent the IRS to investigate.
Hopefully those dinkuses came up with a solution
when I get inside.
But while I'm at it, I'm going to the real estate agent
because this acorn wants a hoose.
Hello.
No, wait, you're another real estate agent.
Hi, real estate agent.
Hello, you found me a client.
All they had for a budget is elite.
That's not exactly currency.
Well, the economy really has sunk, hasn't it?
Here, do you mind taking this then?
Do you mind taking them then?
I can sell them a thought they're standing on.
Real estate letter.
It's a leaf worth of land.
Okay, yeah, sure, and I'll give them my house.
Right, we're going to...
Oh, I literally, I'm glowing.
I just noticed that.
I thought they were all just saying that for funsies.
No, I'm literally irradiated right now.
Ipsy, oh wait.
Am I supposed to put the cat here?
You found a sword.
Either way, we shouldn't be the ones doing this weird.
Is there tax money even going?
Politicians, am I right?
Wait until I tell you about what an abyssalman is.
Are you ready?
Remember how there's that contract for a one single lane to be opened up in America?
And the contract was priced at 310 million US dollars?
Are those dollars going to the workers that are put in the roads and the road
are put in the tarmac then?
Of course not.
That's what an abyssalman is called.
People are giving contracts to each other all the time.
It literally happened with COVID in the UK.
Richie Snack and all his wee pals got all these billions of fucking contracts and fucking
great British pounds.
And then everyone was like, that's not worth it.
That's not this, that's not that.
Yeah, it's called abyssalman.
Okay, thank Tarnett.
Can you read for me?
I cannot.
You own real estate.
You also own property tax.
No property tax for you.
Is that how you read?
Sometimes.
Nice.
Now get off my property.
Sorry.
Gosh, she's so smart and hot.
I came across a TikTok that was talking about it and everyone was like, the road
isn't worth that much.
What's going on?
And I'm like, you guys don't know what an abyssalman is?
Like, there was so many comments that had no comprehension about what an abyssalman is.
I was already farting everyone's eyelashes.
Like, how can you not know what an abyssalman is?
So I'm going to do a tinfoil hat stream because I need to, I need, I need to teach
the masses what the fuck goes on in, you know, because it's not clicking.
Okay.
I know you don't get taught it on purpose, but holy fuck.
Holy fuck, holy fuck.
Right, okay.
Let's go to the, we, the hat, okay.
We're playing dead by daylight right now.
We're going to the hat.
Can we get in?
Okay.
Hi guys.
What's the deal?
Hello, Tarnett boy.
Bunker closed tight.
I used my muscles.
No success.
We call touch at grim graveyard.
Maybe he has tool.
Goodbye.
Okay.
We go to the graveyard.
Thanks for the listen.
She's so smart.
I want to drown in her clams.
Stop.
Should I order or work it out?
You guys send me memes and marshmallow to like keep me up to date with everything because
I'm not, I don't, I don't always have time to keep up the date with everything.
And one of them was like, oh, she's so smart.
I want to drown in her.
Okay.
Hello.
I think I'm doing your quest next.
All right, kid.
What do you want from me?
The IRS called and told me to help boy Tarnett.
And I'm going to assume that's you.
My shovel.
Why I make a living with this darn thing.
All right.
Fine.
If you want it so bad, you're going to have to work for it.
There's some rich folk buried deep in this graveyard.
Help me find them and I'll give you my shovel.
I never said I made a living with a strong set of weight with grave robin.
If you're set in, let's get going.
Let's get going because no one's.
Oh my God.
It's Emmy.
Hi, Emmy.
I can't do any boys.
Go to where the trees rot or you'll return to the pot.
What?
Go to where the trees rot or you'll return to the bottom.
Like you'll leave.
It's a riddle.
Okay.
The trees rot.
Well, there's rotten trees at that archway.
What?
Kid, why are you looking at me with that confused look on your dumb face?
When in doubt, just start digging.
You won't believe what these idiots are buried.
You don't need the shovel for that.
You have a perfectly good sword.
I think we're, I think we're grave robin.
An ironic.
Whoa.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stop it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm not surprised we're getting haunted for grave robin.
Going to be honest.
Uh, am I the only one that gets a song of storm waves from this background?
Okay.
What's your advice?
The direction to go that's the best will reigns with best.
Listen, man.
It's hard to come up with good riddles.
Where?
North, east, west, surely it's west.
Sure.
Okay.
So I just, I had a little bit of doubt.
I had a little bit of doubt.
I had a bit of doubt.
I'm, I'm special.
Okay.
I was like, does east reign with best?
But does it?
Or is it like an American accent thing?
Maybe I'm just overthinking it.
I'm sorry.
Please forgive me.
Oh, hi.
Unless you want to join me below, seek the truth where it's yellow.
Bug off, dude.
It almost rhymes.
I rip it up.
Hey, mom and dad.
I don't know why I'm writing when you're six feet under,
but I just want to say thanks for leaving the farmland to me.
It's a great place to raise kids.
Is that real?
Honestly though, couldn't have paid the debt off before you passed the taxes are insane.
I guess those are just developers because there's no way to put like actual wings in it.
That's rather strange.
I assume yellow is below, right?
Seek the truth where, if you want me to join below.
Oh, I thought you said weas.
It's so funny.
What?
All right.
Dead trees.
West.
It's the yellow flowers.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
It's the yellow flower.
This area seems to have the remains of humans.
Everything that's left behind warps our technology and ability.
So the shoo, I'm so sorry.
If you want to be right, you better get out of my sight.
I'm not trying to be mean.
It's the riddle.
Okay.
I guess we use the teleport one.
But that teleport hardly laugh.
If you want to be right, get out of my sight.
Wait.
Oh, I'm going to have to push Sun through here.
Hold on.
Okay.
I actually have to use my brain mildly for this one.
Oh, shit.
No.
Hold on.
I'm not very smart.
If the portal could last like five seconds longer, that would genuinely be appreciated.
Okay.
I assume it's going to be right because...
Because why wouldn't it be?
Okay.
This is a good one.
I think only one of these pumpkins is completely honest.
The rest seem like they're lying about the duration and who they believe is a liar.
My brain hurts.
Just figure it out.
Oh, no.
You should go west.
All the pumpkins on my right are lying.
You should go north.
All the pumpkins on my right is lying.
You should go east.
All the pumpkins.
Follow me.
I'm telling the truth.
You should go south.
All the pumpkins.
Follow me.
I'm telling the truth.
What?
You should go south.
Oh, no.
That's not happening.
We flinch.
What's the answer?
That's not...
It's 5 a.m.
5 a.m.
What one is it?
It's all...
Oh, sorry.
I didn't see the ghost.
That's right.
I'm Grave Robyn.
What are you going to do about it?
Don't tell her.
Don't make me...
I will just fucking...
I will stun Locke right now.
It's 8 p.m.
You need to do the last one.
Talk to the last one?
The one that's face...
Oh.
You should go south.
Also, the pumpkin above me is telling the truth.
You should go east.
What?
I don't...
Can't do it without the last pumpkin.
There's a pumpkin you haven't talked to.
You should go west.
Also, the pumpkin above me is lying.
I don't know how you're supposed to do the process of elimination thing with these.
You should go...
If only one is telling the truth,
then any statement claiming that the other is telling the truth cannot be...
The only...
So, the one that says...
Truth.
So, there's only one that says lying.
So, the bot middle is the correct one.
Oh no, he says lying too.
The pumpkin on my right is lying.
The pumpkin above me is lying.
You should go south.
Also, the reefling above me is telling the truth.
Stop.
I swear, if I'm doing a maze because of you guys.
Reefling!
Mods!
Mods, time out that reefling.
I fucking believed you!
I believed you!
Reefling!
I've already forgotten which way is which!
You know I'm not smart enough for this stuff!
Stop teasing me!
You're fucking teasing me!
Right, we went south.
It's not south.
So, we're just gonna go north.
The pumpkin is it.
Another one is telling the truth.
Mine is south and east.
So, I think you're meant to go north.
Okay, you're lucky.
You're lucky.
I got a shovel.
Can I pick up?
Oh snap, kiddo!
We've struck the mother load!
Now that I have a brand new shiny shovel,
I guess you don't need this honka-junk.
Take this.
I'll get rid of the gross soil for you for your charge.
I found the shovel!
A mighty weapon, hints harder,
and can pry open bunkers.
Are you gonna be fine, okay?
Are you okay?
No secrets?
No little cheeky secrets?
No?
Okay.
All right, I'll see you later, I'll get you.
You should go east.
Also, the reefling who said south is right.
So, I guess I'll just push me back to the start.
Okay, I've got the shovel.
We can pry open the bunker now.
Check the graves for secrets.
SHIT!
Fuck!
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Hold on, right.
Um, what was it?
Dead trees.
A little to the left.
And then the flowers.
And then the teleport.
And then, was it north?
I think it was north.
Okay, and then we're gonna beat up the graves.
Oh, a little heart, some stuff.
I'm digging a grave.
Diggy diggy grave.
I'm being a grave.
Oh my god, the shovel's so much stronger than the sword.
It only takes...
Oh, I never saw him.
I'm getting walloped by a freaking phantom.
The phantom.
To say ghost in French, you say phantom.
Bunk.
Oh, there's no bonus.
Oh, I got my hearts back.
Sure you don't want to give me that shovel?
Didn't check the graves in the first area.
And I just...
All reflings are liars.
Also, any statement I say is false.
Stop, because I literally can't do that stuff.
Wait, I very quickly checked the graves here.
And just build it.
I'm just...
I'm just doing dead bodies, right?
Let's not...
We'll leave the dead bodies alone.
Forget about the graves.
Forgot about the graves in the second area.
A mint phantom.
I hear the phantom in French means ghost.
Right, fine.
We'll do the second area.
And if nothing happens, you're all getting bent over many...
Right, no, dead trees.
Okay.
I'm getting trolled by you guys.
I'm just digging up dead bodies.
I have no respect for the dead right now.
You know, it's like really bad.
Now, you guys are trolls!
Why are you trolling me?
There's nothing here.
It's the one you did first.
Slam Girl for Gen 2 also to tell in the truth.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the one you did first.
World domination is going great.
It's the one on the right, trust.
Please spank it.
Are you trolled?
Am I getting trolled or not?
I can't tell.
Have you guys played this game before?
I feel like I'm getting mildly trolled right now.
The second zone was the first one you dug.
It's time to leave.
Right, yous are getting spanked.
Just just bent over.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Mini carrot?
Uh, is that a paradox?
The Pinocchio paradox?
Thank you for the super chat.
Um, I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't...
I think that's a paradoxical one, is it not?
What the?
Right, head against side.
Okay.
Really, he would explode?
Interact.
What should you do in a radio-stain form?
Stay prepared. Bunker up, stand side.
Stay tuned. Why would I rip that up?
Fuck it!
Doomsday, you tore up a nuclear hazard and from...
Humans?
There's humans in this game?
Humans.
I'm just a little reefling.
I promise I'm not gonna hurt you.
Ow!
Can I ward myself? Jesus.
Human, come back!
Human, no, don't lock yourself away!
Human, please.
I'm a nice person.
Interact.
Bombs drop. We're gonna stop the virus.
Tax day postpone.
Fuck this!
News boy, you ripped up an old newspaper.
News boy.
Okay.
We have a key.
Are we actually gonna see?
I'm not gonna hurt you. Burn the house down, honestly.
I see it.
I'm spanking it.
Whoa! My controls are inverted!
Oh my god, my controls are inverted.
What the heck?
I'm not... I do not have the brain capacity for that.
So, what's this?
I've been so bored down here.
We stocked up on everything about entertainment.
So, we've been watching the same few movies on repeat forever.
Ooh, that would be rough.
That would be rough.
Right, we need to make a fire.
Oops, sorry.
We go like this, this, this,
and then we burn it
and we take a step back because I don't want to get hurt.
And I'll let him burn it.
Okay.
Whoa!
Stop it, I saw that!
I brought the cupboard.
Oh, I'm bringing things to life, dumbass!
I'm bringing things to life.
Your diary, what's profit?
It's Liz again!
It's what, day 1000?
What, four years?
I thought we would be back home.
My family's driving me crazy.
I feel like you're the only one I can open up to.
I really miss Matt. I was hoping when all this over gets home,
he'd come back to normal.
See you tomorrow, diary.
Whoa! This is like getting a bit real, I think.
Honestly, I don't know.
Right, well, water it, but I don't know if it's going to catch.
Ow! Oh my God, I have to...
Ow, ow, ow!
Stop.
Did I have to catch myself on fire for this?
Oh my God, I do!
Ow, ow, ow! Stop!
How's Matt's suit?
Can't protect me from many things, including fire.
Okay.
Thank you because I'm getting wrecked and decked
and shh, wrecked.
Did I need to ward this?
Turn away.
Hopefully we'll get some health soon,
but apparently I'm not going to be on fire all the time.
Oh my God, it's doing the reverse thing.
Stop with your hypnosis. I'm the hypnosis.
One, okay.
Stop it!
I'm the hypnosis one.
Oh my God, I'm actually going to die in this game.
I think I'm going to have to back it.
Stop!
It keeps putting me backwards.
I think I'm going to have to keep coming back in and out
to spawn the health.
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
Why did you put the fucking backwards one
right next to it, bro?
I swear if I lost all that progress.
No, I didn't. Okay, it's fine.
First death, honestly.
I hate this game. Sorry.
It's going to zero out ten.
Virginia, that's to me. I'm so embarrassed.
Wait, I thought I had a hazmat suit on.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Wait, hold on. Let me check my inventory.
No, I do have the hazmat suit.
So things shouldn't be
freaking doing that. Stop it.
Wait, hold on, hold on. I got this.
Oh no, I need to destroy them.
Oh my God, please. He's right there.
Please.
Right there.
I can handle this one. That's fine.
Okay.
Is it easier
just to burn myself?
I know that sounds crazy, but...
I think that's what the game wants me to do.
Oh, wait. I can burn myself without...
Okay, okay. I can burn myself
without taking damage. Got it.
Got it. Got it.
I understand.
Okay, sorry, I love this game again.
Sorry, I love this game.
Then you set myself on fire.
I don't think I've ever had the puzzle
be like, yeah, nuke yourself.
Okay.
Quit the suit. You haven't put it on.
The suit is on.
Like, it doesn't display.
Dad left the bunker last week
to scout what's been happening above.
I don't know what he saw, but he hasn't been the same since.
He saw fruit?
We're in a radioactive world, look.
Stop!
Eh?
Um...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, this stuff creeps me out.
This stuff creeps me out. Nope, nope, nope.
We're not doing this.
Burn me!
No!
Um...
Oh my god, I can't do the long-arm stuff.
Oh my god, it freaks me out.
It freaks me out. I can't...
Put me on fire. Put me on fire.
Is it working? Her HP is going down,
but my HP is going down too.
Stop touching me.
Stop it.
I don't want...
Oh god, no.
Ow, no, I'm dead. Holy crap, I don't know what to do.
The best second is
literally just keep myself on fire.
No, can you maybe put me on fire?
What the fuck is this boss fight?
And there's no...
Okay, so it is to like
put her on fire. Hold on.
I don't... Sorry, I wasn't quite
comprehending what I was supposed to do. Let's try that again.
Shouldn't the suit protect you from radiation?
Mutated girl for Gen 2.
Right, let's try that again.
Maybe avoid getting hit by the fifth?
So I just lighter on fire?
I think... Right.
There. Okay, she's on fire.
And... Okay, that's fine.
No, that's not fine.
Can you put me on fire please?
And then hit her with the fire. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I just needed a bit of
a bit of like, uh, what does the game want
for me, you know?
There we go. Okay, she did.
She walloped me. She got me good there.
I'll admit it, you got me good.
Right, so when she pukes, I can't actually
really, you know, do anything with it.
I can put on fire.
Okay.
Right, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
That was a much better attempt. I'm not really sure
how you do that hit list, but sure.
No, I'll pick up. I'll pick up.
Heart fruit. Very happy with that.
Not gonna complain.
Hey.
What can I like, pry their bunker open?
I guess not.
He's done it hit list.
Strony irradiated and kills the child, but she's
a laser pointer.
She shoots a red laser beam.
Fancy stuff.
I miss Grom. He was the best cat I've ever had.
I can't stand to look at his little toys.
The laser pointer was his favorite. Aw, is it me
putters this toy?
Right.
So I guess we can go in there?
No, I guess not.
Hmm.
Ha.
Ha, ha, ha.
Okay, that was a
interesting little tidbit.
So humans
actually live in this world and exist in
this world.
It definitely
changed the tone a bit.
I'm starting it for bud.
Trying to pry the door open.
I'm just like, excuse me, I would like to talk.
I'm just a little turnip.
Hello.
Dear Dyr, after being in this bunker
so long, I've gotten so clear. I can't wait to see the sun again.
You found hair dye.
Can make leaves blue, a hot commodity
amongst barbers.
I know who to give that to.
Do da, do da.
Okay, that was a very
interesting
story.
Now I'm a sucker
for a radiation and fallout
story. So I have to admit, I'm very sucked
into the plot right now.
Okay, I've got your laser pointer.
Yes, the laser pointer. The final piece
of my master plan.
You really thought I was going to give you the D to your green?
Yes.
I don't know how to laugh like that.
You really are an idiot just like father.
Do you even know what's even under
your own home?
This is pathetic.
Get on my side, I bet the
infamous old man lemon won't help you there.
Go to my house, you bam.
Go to my house.
Right, I'm giving the barber
his dye, okay.
The evil mirror was evil.
Interact.
Ooh, you with that intrusive hair cut.
Do you have a hair dye?
Thank you, fine sir.
I must repair your good deed.
Do not worry, the great Edgar
shall fix that monstrosity
of a Jew.
He's oars, just cut it all off.
Oh my god, mercy's in the game.
Oh no, I think...
I mean, I can still...
Yeah, I can work with that.
Can you hear me right now?
Oh, did it?
I completely like glossed over that.
Stash power, thank you for the super chat.
I completely like didn't
think either.
Hello chat.
Well, yes, it's time to tell you the truth.
Your father,
Daunton,
Mayor Onion and I go way back.
We used to run
in the same crime family.
We were all mobsters.
Your father was the boss.
I was hit, man.
Mayor Onion was the consigliary.
Consigliary.
What?
Well, that's some French piss I've never seen in my life.
Emmy, translate please.
Consigliary.
It sounds like a piece of pasta.
Alright.
Our society
is chaotic.
We have no laws.
No one in charge.
It was a perfect time to take control,
but we had our disagreements.
Mayor Onion got filled with greed.
He had his own beliefs on how
the town should be ran.
We thought he was just a bit
of a quack. We didn't think
he would take it this far.
We formed a government, turning
us and dragging our names in the dirt.
Huh?
He wanted what we have
in our base.
Hello. Weapons.
Wealth. You name it. We had it.
Huh?
I believed that
he would go to great lengths.
I always thought your father's death was
suspicious.
Hmm.
You thought this was about your greenhouse?
Sonny, there's a massive base
underneath it.
Hmm.
You must go now. Sneaking
and defeat Mayor Onion.
There's not much time.
Ehhh.
You can use my secret hatch behind this tree.
But be quick.
We are pissed. There's a time.
Hold on. I need a hydration check.
The voices are killing me a bit. Hydration
replays. I think we're about to do the
boss fight.
Uh, how badly am I
going to mess up this boss fight?
Be honest.
I'm coming at them while
my bowl is headed in.
Mysterious
Mafia base.
Ooh.
Oh, there's trash.
I mean, it makes sense that we
use it trash.
Right, why doesn't it be on fire?
What?
I can't get there in time.
Maybe another time.
Basic English for big dum-dum
tax addition.
You destroyed the book that taught
everyone how to speak.
Oops.
Us veggies learn right, we big brain.
Ah, no!
Is that our first word?
Oopsies.
I'm not sure if we still got that.
Oh, I need to
I need to teleport.
Oh my god, I need to teleport.
I don't know if I can do this in time.
Oh my god, I can, right.
I have to admit, they really do not
give you much time for those portals.
Right.
Sorry, my brain's kind of
short circuiting right now.
I'm like, oh, sorry.
If I do that, okay, that'll do.
Right, and then
I get into the teleport thing.
Bonk.
And then
bonk.
And then bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk.
All done.
Oh shit, it's all puzzles.
What was in the other room?
Hold on, hold on.
Let me try the other room first.
Cause...
Interact.
B2.
The layers to the onion.
The mirror onion manifest.
Get it out of here.
What even is the point of the mafia?
I want wealth and these deadbeats
aren't going to get me. I've been learning
about the humans and their government.
Perhaps I will make more or maybe I can convince Dawn.
Wait, it's all puzzles always has been.
I accidentally played the puzzle game.
He's lost the headless, charred,
pickled gang.
Great. General grapefruit.
My wife, J.K. Lowell.
What? My wife.
My wife.
Okay, let's go down again.
Where is this? I think maybe we need to wait.
According to her research, whatever
being lived on the planet before us were destroyed
by these devices, we need to dismantle this
if we want to protect our future.
I'll have onion do it, Dawn.
That's how my daddy died.
Oh my god.
It was all
mirror onion's fault.
We have learned the lore.
We must explore now.
They weren't lying about having weapons
under the damn house.
Okay, let's see
what I'm supposed to do over here.
That looks like a nuke.
Great.
Let's just
fucking go where we can.
Oh, interact.
My survival. Oh no!
My surviving son.
If you read this, I've probably been rotten for a while now.
I've lest this state to you, but I fear
mirror onion's retaliation. Please do protect yourself.
And the
Ternichino
land is all up to you now. I'm sorry
that I couldn't be there to witness your second leaf.
Oh!
Or for when you held your first watering can,
I'll miss you, son. You'll be the biggest gangster
of us all. I know you'll make the
Ternichino name proud.
P.S., destroy this letter. I don't want the IRS
to see this. Love you, Dawn.
Oh my dad.
Thank you for the letter, dad.
I now have closure.
You ripped up a letter from your dad.
Bruh, this is...
Wait, is that my family?
Stop! Oh my god, it's me!
That's so funny that they've pixelated
the pictures on it.
Right, I have closure from my dad now.
I understand.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do.
No, I don't understand.
Right. Hold on.
Wait, hold on. I need to kick the bomb
upwards.
So, I need to do this.
Then I need to do this.
And then quickly jump down.
Do that. And then up!
Okay.
And then do it again.
Oh my god. Up, up, up, up, up, up!
Quick, quick! Okay.
Oh shit. Wait, what?
Ugh!
Oh shit.
Oh, I need to destroy it.
You're meant to destroy the Sith,
not join it!
You underestimated my power.
Don't try it, anything.
Anyway, that's my recap of Star Wars.
If you want that to know.
Why does it keep shoving it there?
Oh my god, I'm going to fart in its mouth!
Alright, I'm going to let the portal
time out, okay?
No, this is pod racing.
I want to do it.
Right, I guess I'll put it here.
You almost got it.
Unironically...
Oh wait, I need to destroy it.
Unironically, a little to the left.
And then go up.
Let me come up too.
You're such a liar!
Out my way!
No, you're such a liar, honestly.
Not here.
Yeah, do that.
Oh wait, I don't need to destroy it.
Oh my god, we did it!
Oh hell yeah!
You can't hold me back.
I'm coming to avenge my father.
You think you're a wise guy, huh?
Did you get any success?
Wackum, you idiot radishes!
No, leave me alone!
Sorry, I just walked into them.
Enough!
What the...
You stupid baba ganoush!
That's just so one battery yet is!
That's it, I'm sick of your garbage.
You'll be sleeping with a rot in the night.
Corrupt political powers.
Transform!
Eh?
Corruption onion.
I can't even hit him.
Okay, one hit.
Ow!
How did I drop bombs on him?
Did I not even have access to any bombs or anything?
Every time he does a...
I got stuck in the corner!
Ow!
I don't know if I should just go for a whack
every time he does an attack.
I don't know.
Okay, we can hit two whacks.
Oh no no no!
We can get two whacks in when he does a move.
One, two.
Run away.
And then...
Two...
Oh!
He threw up, he did.
Okay, okay, okay.
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
Let's try that again, let's try that again.
Elden Ring boss, right?
You think...
Bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk.
Yes, yes, yes.
Red storm!
Okay, let's try again, let's try again, let's try again.
Roll, use those...
Use those eye frames real untrue.
Corruption, onion.
Okay, let him...
Whack.
Oh for fuck's sake!
I'm stuck in...
That wouldn't have happened
if their controls weren't B for interact.
I wouldn't have got stuck there.
I can't believe that I'm losing to a pixel game.
Can I hit him? Oh I can!
You can get a few extra whacks
and get lucky with the leader.
One, and two.
Okay, close enough.
Unfortunate stealth, one.
Oh shit, that was really obvious, I shouldn't have done that.
Sorry.
One, two, three.
And four, and then he attacks.
Ow, he hit me.
Stop it, I'm supposed to hit you.
Stop it.
Okay, and one, two.
Close enough.
One, ow.
One, two, three.
How could this happen?
How was I bestowed by the...
How was I bested? Sorry.
How was I bested by the son of my rival?
He might have defeated me,
but the government will live on
through the documentary mess.
Oh shit, really?
Oh!
How many ha-has are there?
Right, we did it.
Shit.
You committed tax evasion, achievement unlocked.
I cannot laugh for that long.
How did I miss any documents?
I've got everything.
Property deed, the greenhouse owned by Turnip Boy.
Enough!
You ripped up your own deed of homeowner.
That was so cute.
Amazing voice acting, did you like it?
With us.
We gathered here to say farewell.
We'll go next along.
So, sing along.
Or don't.
Do you?
Sing along.
Little adventure through the land.
Take down mayor onion.
Always leave your plans.
We won't pay our taxes.
We've got rent and we've got bills.
Those layers...
I wish they gave you lyrics.
I could have sang along.
Little adventure through the land.
Take down mayor onion.
Always leave your plans.
Spend some time peeling back
those skins in your finder.
Soon there are seeds with
and we'll sing
our hearts out loud.
We'll spin because the worst
parts pass
we're breathing still.
So we'll fight
through the woods.
The violence of history
we're speaking in ethos.
The secret is to try
doing good.
People snails alone.
They got problems of their own.
Make your mark.
Cause it's time.
Always lose.
Wasted for a paste of
friends and family make up.
Fertile or that heart.
You need to sing this in the next track, ok?
You played the sequel?
There's a sequel?
I would definitely play the sequel.
Fertile or that heart.
We rob a bank, do we?
Oh my god, that's so good.
Oh, what a nice ending message to the family.
There was a big dev team, but I guess it was one guy.
There's more to the game.
I think the end?
Question mark?
I don't know.
Well, we go explore those areas that were stuck.
I took a dinner break and it's the end credit.
No, no, there's more.
Okay, let me turn it down again because I have to turn it up for that singing section.
Wait, turn it down for the actual gameplay section.
All aboard!
Sunset station has finally been constructed.
Check your mailbox.
Dimensional disruptions have been occurring in a cave in Rocky Brant.
Maybe go check it out.
Limitless line.
I'm a serious train checker.
I wonder where I can use it.
Is this DLC?
The 100% speedrun for this game is 24 minutes.
Eh!
Is this DLC?
Because I was hoping for...
Is this a 2 over DLC mission thing?
Or is this the true ending?
How long is it?
Because I purposely picked shorter games so I can get the background work.
She didn't get the true ending.
Should we come back to it then?
No, it's pretty short.
Okay, I'll come here.
Daily challenge.
Hi, random people who are playing this game.
It's short.
Okay, okay, okay.
I trust, I trust.
Oh, sorry.
All aboard!
Depart and sunset station.
Tickets, please.
Oh, turn it, boys.
See, you got complimentary sunset station ticket in the mail.
It's named this because of the odd way this area always looks like the sun is setting.
Ah.
No loitering at the station now.
It's time to get aboard.
Get your stubs moving and let's get the show on the road.
Okay.
The limitless line.
Oh, I'm supposed to spank everything.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
It's like a fighter.
Oh, there's sheep.
Oh my God, it's the Binding of Isaac.
Can I make it to the end, is the question.
Even though the song literally said leave the snails alone, they've got problems of their own.
The Binding of Turnips.
Eat a ton of ferret.
Wait, again?
No.
Spank, spank, spank.
Turn into bacon right now.
Bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon.
Okay.
Bacon.
We have bacon.
You beat stuff up until you lose.
It's basically Bostra.
Is it endless?
So it doesn't matter.
Good show.
Eh?
I'm sure you've noticed, but this is no ordinary train, buckle.
It's time for you to tap deep into your mafioso blood.
A mafioso must be resourceful.
They must be cunning.
They must be charming.
Hm?
All things you don't possess.
Excuse me.
So we're here to work on it.
Hm.
Here are some train-exclusive trinkets.
Choose wisely.
They could make or break your time on the limitless line.
Increases your trip range.
Makes you go zoom.
Chances for enemies to explode on death.
Is that dangerous to me?
Fuck it, we'll take the explosion.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Breta.
Bre.
Don't touch me like that.
I really cannot handle the long arm thing.
Stop, and then give me another one.
Stop it.
Okay, the explosion one definitely seems to be helping.
It's just bending of Isaac's turnip.
Stop.
You stop it.
Ow.
Okay.
Rotten cat apple has buttered toast.
No, you stop spinning right now.
You're scaring me.
Stop it.
Spank.
No.
Stop it.
Naughty.
You're not getting any catnip after dinner tonight.
Bad kitty.
Spank.
Spank, spank, spank, spank.
And I have two tickets.
So, do I not need to do this bit?
Is it a different bit I need to do?
Good show.
They say cats just have nine lines, but that's not necessarily true.
Eh?
Okay.
Chance to not take damage.
Increase trip.
Chance for enemies to catch on fire when hit.
Why would you need defensive everything's dying around you?
Stop it.
No, dear girl for Gen 4.
Stop it, Sheebie.
I don't care if you want to slime girl, Sheebie.
It's not happening.
Stop.
Okay.
Maybe I should have done the defense one.
I don't know.
Okay.
He caught on fire.
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
Fucking radiation.
A crew member of nature.
Spank.
Oh my God, the fire's so OP.
Whoa, it's so OP.
It's literally so OP.
It's so OP.
Why no deer girl?
I thought you had good tape?
Good show for Gen 4.
Wanklin. Speedrun strat. Just like the deer and headlights, but the headlights are just
your lifeless BDIs. Alright, on the next car you go. Don't take damage, zoom, or no,
don't take damage, so we're going full defense often. Oh wait, there was a person I could
have spoke to. I see the enemy! You have overcome the challenges of the dream and now you face
the face with the conductor and the final boss, or perhaps I'm just the beginning. Let's
put on a good show. Show me what you're made of. Oh, get away from me, you bum! Get away
from me. No, go on fire, go on fire right now. No. His teleportation literally cheats
he diddles him from the burn. You're such a cheater. Fuck you, bitch. Ow, you're hurting
me. Stop it, get on fire right now. No. Oh my god, I don't have the fricking, I don't
have the framerate to respond to this. Please catch on fire. I'm just avoiding these ones.
Okay, just three stars. Oh my god, I don't have enough reaction time for this, I genuinely
don't. This is why I like Isaac, because as soon as they give me the fricking leaf one,
I'm good to go. Oh, well, I blocked that, I was lucky. Stop! Right, two, and then the
third one, and then attack. Fuck you. Okay, see, see the fire is like literally keeping
me alive. Fuck you, bitch. Do you think we'll do it? We're both on one HP, can I do it?
Without fucking it up. Oh my god, I got an achievement. Defeat the conductor. One HP
and a dream. Good show, turnip boy. You still aren't cunning enough for charming, but you
got Matthew also blood in you. I don't think I can continue, bro. I ain't feeling so good.
Good show. Now it's time to pick your last trinket. What, you thought you were done?
Yeah, going through the train once is not enough to prepare you for what comes. Whether
it's fighting the likes of my brother or dodging the IRS, you'll be doing this forever. Always
bashing baddies, always moving, always facing me. Car to car it goes, for this is limit
list. It only gets harder. Chance to heal on enemy death. Well, yeah, I'm gonna, what
do you do? You know this train is really killing all but I just wish it had Wi-Fi so I could
play Ocean of Stealing. Infinite train, now give me that infinite bandwidth. Real untrue.
Oh, you're not off. Oh yeah, it appears to run a train and it's infinite, right? Okay,
okay, okay, we get it. Wrap it up, wrap it up, we get it, we get it, we get it. Okay,
the train's infinite, thank you. I am dead, okay. Faint on limits line. I got an achievement
for that. Continue? Okay, that was interesting. Woo, what are you? Allows you to participate
in the daily challenge run. Cowboy hat and sandwich ring. Okay, that wasn't, we'll go
with the mains. The children yearn for the mains. You can see a teaser reference. I'm
sure it was this one. At the, my turn. Luckily, that wasn't what you had to do for the extra
stuff. I don't understand, was this train an infinite? Sadly, yeah. Okay, we're gonna
go into the mains because we've unlocked it now. Assume that's what the post game stuff
is. I'm digging a hole. Woo! Hi. Meow. Hello, living rutter bagger. Meow. I can see all the
artifacts you have missed in the past across the dimensional plane. Let's speak further
if you wish to embark. Okay, okay, okay, okay. Seek some software from a bell tepher. Oh my
God, so it helps me. What the fuck does that mean? A bell pepper? Have I even spoken to
a bell pepper? Show us what you missed for the true ending. I don't even recall interacting
with a bell pepper. The barber? He already cut my shit off. How can he fuck me up even
more? You must be, it was me that fixed your hair. It seems like your hair was the biggest,
ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, anymore. Are you a bell pepper? Thank you for delivering it. Since
you helped me in my business, the only thing I can do is help you. Here's a copy of five
books you can figure out how to do taxes. Ah, rip it up. Okay, okay, okay, okay. And then we go
back to the cat. Bell pepper? Wait, what are you? What? How do you say bell pepper? Well,
excuse me fucking. Um, can I have some bell pepper on my subway sandwich? Yeah, so how
do you say that? Yeah, you go bell pepper. Bell pepper. A bell pepper. Hello. I can see that
you missed. Speak to me if you want to embark. Seek some fan art from a cranberry. Who is a
cranberry? Bell pepper? Bell pepper? Hardly even know it. Who is a cranberry? Does anyone
know where the cranberry is? Any cranberry lovers? You want to spray cranberry? Yeah,
remember that me? Remember that ancient fucking me? I don't know where the cranberry is. I don't
know. Here blueberry. I love cranberries. That's right. I'm being up. Where's this cranberry?
Oh, the graveyarder. Isn't a cranberry guy? Wait, you're still in my house, you bum. I phoned
a valve. Open your mind. Open your eyes. I knave her. Oh, I'm just like getting props to
stick on my head. Gobble, gobble. The band. We're going to cram your berry, you bear. Oh,
you got a little chicken on your head. A little chickadiddy. We've got cranberries over here. Are
you a cranberry or are you just an orange? I don't remember talking to a cranberry. She's in
Veggieville. An old lady. You have to find her cat. You've got to find an old lady's puss puss.
Blueberry. Hey, dude, scram. You don't know me. Yeah, well, you help when the pick up. Dang,
you seem a bit young for this, but hey, I don't think there was just like this through the
top of their jar and they can handle it from there. Oh, I do help them escape. Okay, let's
start blowing stuff up. She's in the south. The other wieflings are right. Okay, she's south.
We've got free heart this whole time. Shocking behavior. I can't believe we're 100% in this game.
We're such gamers. Time to bust the boys out. Me and the boys. Right, let's get the old ladies one
wherever she is. Hello. Wait, what? Are she like south, south? You're a strawberry.
Well, that was rude. Sorry. I don't remember where the pickle gang is either.
So you're a watermelon.
I don't remember. Shadow, shadow was your money game. Wait, try talking to the red cat in the garden.
The secret ending is when you're too high. We go on LSD. I'm just a little turn it.
Mind in his business. Let's talk to the red key.
Oh, it's my little apple munchkin. I found this thing called mango in the forest and tried to
replicate the art style. Hope you like it. What? Wait, I'm a girl. You're a girl, riefling.
Waifu. You destroyed a waifu.
Girl this whole time. Well, bend over. I'm clapping you. No, the devs were just high. Oh,
the devs were high. Oh, okay. Hello, Mr. Kitty. Yes, yes, yes, yes, please tell me.
Seek a document about an app on a phone.
I can't do anything with that. Literally called turn it, boy. Also law-abiding citizen in
pain types is real untrue. You had a hairpin in the family photo. My god, I'm a girl.
My pintas. Are you okay? These carrots have accepted acorn as their own. I know carrot. Okay.
Oh, you're a cranberry. Right. Are you a cherry? I'm going to just leave it to you, do you think?
Something in here.
The forsake in house doesn't have the pickles in it. Does it? Oh, no, it does. Okay.
Right here. Thanks, we owe you one here. Try this out. Your father used to wear one
back in the day. Every good mafia still needs to lose their part. Oh, you got fedora. My lady.
Oh my god, look at handsome you look.
A very flavored kiss should heal you right up. Oh my god, we got a kiss. Oh my god, she heals us
for free. Right, are you getting out or what? Well, this is goodbye. You won't see us around these
parts. I mean, trying to get pinched. Good luck with that tax evasion, I remember. I didn't like
your father, but he would have been proud. I turned myself into a pickle sorority.
Right, I don't know where this app thing, I think you guys are going to have to,
you need to go to the Forgotten Forest for the next one. Okay, thank you. Let's just Cheesy Doodle,
because I do have to edit Mercy's ASMR next. She should have a role play up tomorrow.
I'll do the same thing where two hours before her stream time, it goes up. I think that,
I'm sorry, I accidentally just, but I'm doing bad at doing this.
And then, if the site is giving me her lines, I'll have an ASMR up as well. It's in the second
area. You said ga ga gigi, and when turning into the lollipop, it should be
What are you on about? What are you smoking?
Can't believe it, Riflin, you're smoking without me.
Kering, I actually have never done any recreational drugs, because it's not safe for me.
Okay, there's something in the forest. Oh my god, that's it. Thanks again, you're welcome.
I completely forgot where the prompt from the cat was.
I completely, you smoke? Oh, I never might know.
If it became legal, I'd try it for the first time on stream. Why not? Let's see what happens.
What? Can I war again?
Rifling, smoking, rifle. So go back and then go north instead.
Like here? No?
I did buy some, they're pretty good. You did grab a phone, it was by Holly.
The fuck's Holly? You're smoking that turnip, boys. Give me the leaves on your head right now.
The next one is on the upper part of the warm up on the north-east train.
Am I going the wrong way? I'm not supposed to be wrong?
This next one is on the upper part of the lower, you're in the wrong forest. You know what?
Check your inventory for the phone. I just made.
Okay, I need to go to the bottom forest. This is the woods.
She's in the rocky camp, the rocky map. Are you, not your...
Are you Holly? Nope, you're Ellie. Holly, are you Holly? Healy, close enough.
Holly, oh my, you got my phone. Since you obviously care a ton about that in your
webs, can you sign the petition to thought from banning flip-flops? It's one of my favorite
so I have no idea. Get that out of here. You destroyed every single tax document. Now that
you've destroyed all the tax documents, maybe go try and fight the mayor again? Okay, okay.
We honestly didn't miss like that much at all. Right, let's go wallop his arsehole.
Please tell me this is all unblocked. I'm not doing it again. Okay, thank God, because I was,
I'm not doing all that again. Wrap it up. Wrap it up. It's good to be above.
It's time for the true ending.
Oh my God, sorry. It's really messing me up that the action button is to swap.
Oh, I thought I was going to make me do that again. I was like, do you fucking dare, mate? Do
you fucking dare? Right, wallop him and then run away. Okay, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk. Okay,
now go big. Okay, boss fight again, but then we get the true ending.
Went mad with power. Right, let them wallop. One, two, and then one, two, and we can actually
get three with a laser. One, two. Oh my God, can we do a hit list? Can we do a hit list? Come on,
do a hit list. One, two. I can't unfortunately get my wallops in. One, two.
One, two. No, me getting hit lists. Come on. I'm just so MLG like that. Come on, baby. One, two.
I can't hit them because of the gunk. No, I'm doing hit lists, sorry. One, two.
Can I get away with a hit list? No, I jinxed it. Sorry, I jinxed it. Whoops.
One, two, three, four, five. Okay, that's close enough. Right, let's see. Let us see what happens.
Did you think you won? Did you think you'd beat this little game we had going on here?
You think I didn't notice that you destroyed every single government document?
I have one last trick up my sleeve. Did you notice in my basement below? The fucking nuclear bomb?
Yes, it's the nuke. The same nuke your father wanted me to deactivate. Your father was a dead
beat. He thought it was too dangerous to keep around so he wanted me to prevent it from ever
being used. But now that he's not in the picture, guess what? Get nuked, kiddo.
Hello?
What the? What?
Durned boy, Durned boy, are you with us? Wake up. Wake up, Durned boy. I think we've left the atmosphere.
Ridley, how the fuck am I supposed to win against that? Oh, last Durned Boy, I've ascended. I've become
in an unstoppable foe's greater than the mushroom giants in the past. I will bring taxation to the
world. No, to the universe. There will be taxation without representation through the galaxies. Goodbye,
Durned boy. It's time for you to die. Oh, Mars, what is that thing? Durned boy, go find the rest of
the IRS. I'm stuck in here and they're our best bits. Oh, Mars, Durned boy, what do we do? You
become that thing? I need to do something. Something really cash money. Click the
balloon at me. I can try and dunk on him. Remember, don't be the turnip that believes in
Chad. Be the turnip that believes in Durned boy. What? Sorry, that came out suddenly in 2007.
What the fuck? Ray Flinch, you never told me this was part of the game. Oh, shit, I did that wrong.
It's not fucking handsome, Mika. I'm going to cream.
Oh, my God, you're a burpee boy. Burpee boy.
Yeah. Very burpee boy.
Ice ogre, what the fuck? Sorry, I'm trying to try hard, but it's not happening.
What are you doing here? Go find the IRS. Bruh, I'm true.
I'm panicking. Sorry, I'm just trying to see what the math has given me.
You've never warned me about none of this. I can tell you that much. One user in trouble.
I'll fuck off, honestly.
I just need to get the three of them, right?
Is that honestly how to make it? I'm going to cream a bit of this. It sounds like her a little bit.
Oh, sorry. Oh, no, it's all fucking crumbling. What do you do? Hello? I saw what Chad did,
very brief. I will do the same. Give me a bomb. What do you mean, give you a- What are you? You want
me to kick the bomb at you? He fucking sacrifices himself.
What the fuck is going on in this game? Oh, my God.
No, what? I nuked myself? Okay, what's going on with you? Oh, my God, right? Oh, my God, I sacrifice
them all. Oh, he says, dude, what the heck? What was that?
What?
It ain't even appropriate. Oh, my God. What?
Okay, we did it. The real ending.
The high table has been defeated. Oh, fuck yeah. When you put it like that, hold on a minute.
We won. People are allowed to exist without being fucking money funnels.
Oh, okay. Hold on a minute. We did it.
Oh, we did it. What the heck? That was such a bizarre, bizarre game. I 100%
am definitely playing their other game. 100%. There's no way I'm not. Hold on. Let me make myself
big. Big straight.
Okay, big straight. Bizarre. Strony went all the way. No. English folks say that, I don't know.
Oh, British people. It's Shabby up. That was a really good game. Sorry. That was like a 10 out of 10
game. I'm recommending the girls to play that as well. That was fantastic. I will obviously change
the rooms around. Tomorrow, I will do the question thing. If you guys have any funny things that you
don't know about, you're more than welcome. Oh, God, Shabby's doing ASMR. That's perfect.
You guys get me screaming like, what the fuck? We're going to get typed in so that you can die,
and then you're just going to a peaceful Shabby.
Azura's live too. Oh, that's fantastic. Oh my God, there's so many options today.
I appreciate they made possible to get the secret ending even at the end. Yeah,
we can chill with ASMR like that onion there. Yeah. That was a fantastic wee game.
Um, so the plan of action is my little rufflings. Um, that I've got a brave question.
When's the second play? You are pushing your boundary. You're pushing your luck, son. That's
what we see. If you're, um, if you're like a going too far, not in a joking way, you say,
oh, you're pushing your luck. That's what we say. Um, that was fantastic. I thoroughly enjoyed that.
Please do not be surprised when we do turn it boy commits tax evasion.
No, we just played that one. Um, we do the prison one. I think we go, no, we rob a bank. We rob
a bank. Don't be surprised when we rob a bank. It's like perfect stream length. It's fun. It's
engaging all of, well, oh my God, elite gamer jokes in it. Um, so we're definitely going to be doing
that. Um, that was hell of fun. That was a 10 at 10. I'm going to recommend it to the girls. So
if you see them playing it, watch their playthrough as well. Cause that was so fun. Um, yeah, sorry
for the kind of shorter streams this week. However, as I said, there's a lot of content being done in
the background. Uh, we just launched the VTuber Clipping Program. Um, for us in particular, um,
obviously you can clip anyone while you're in it. Um, but you only get paid for clips of
Vila or type thing. It was a lot of fun watching Wometh X Fresh Women. Ah, you're more than welcome.
Um, it was a really good game. Thank you. Thank you. Well, glad you enjoyed it. Um, yes, I will
redirect into Love, Strongly, Getting the Girls to Play Puzzle Games again. It literally is never
ending, but that wasn't hard. Like if I, I figured it out when entering the room for the first time,
I'm sure, then they're a lot smarter than me. All the girls are 100% no doubt, um, in heck,
like way smarter than me. Fun game with a cute and lovely moment. Oh, you're gonna make me blush.
Any amount of time we get, we use amazing. Oh, thank you. Uh, thank you for the stream moment.
Strongly is the puzzle game master. No, thank you for the stream and all the love. I feel,
I feel very reassured yesterday when you guys were like, oh, it's okay if it's a shorter stream,
like if that helps you out. So tomorrow I'm going to be answering the questions. Um,
the meme-y ones, the funny ones, all that jazz. So if you have any funny questions about life or
whatever, you can just throw them in my marshmallow, have a little peek at them. Um, but yeah, tomorrow
is a Zatsu stream, just a two hour experience. The game was almost as cute as, uh, you, jump,
that you're going, hold on a minute, let me fucking actually put my toggles on for one.
You're gonna make me blush. Oh my God, Reefland. Stop it. Imagine if I was actually a skilled
reachable like that. One day, one day, not today though. Um, the game is fun. I'm glad you get
to enjoy. Oh, it's so gay. We said to a good day off, but you don't want to end the streaming
streak real and true. And as I said, when I stream, I don't feel stressed. I feel nice and relaxed.
I'm having a good time. Um, as soon as I hit end broadcast, all the despair comes back, especially
the, like I said, I woke up with separation anxiety. I had to take my little heart medication
because my heart was like thump, thump, thump, thump, and I'm like, I'm streaming soon. It's
fine. It's fine. I don't want to lead the stream. Oh, but you're going to get tingled by Sheebie
though. And little sheepsters. Although my redirects haven't been working very well,
YouTube updated recently. And I think that's why my redirects have been messing up horrifically.
Because it literally says right now that, yep, 100%, I am redirecting into her and I don't
even get what's going on. Um, but yes, please thoroughly enjoy Sheebie Cottonbums tangles.
Don't be afraid to like, subscribe her content. Or like and subscribe this stream. Shit.
Just subscribe to Oliveela. That'd be great. So I can post the artwork because it's so cute.
There's such a cute artwork coming.
Open an old video and shrink the windows. The chat is just rolling by. Thanks to this
stream. No, thank you for this stream. That was so fun. Literally 10 out of 10 game. Thoroughly
enjoyed it. I will swap the titles and the thumbnails very shortly. Please thoroughly
enjoy Sheebie. I will talk to you very soon. Would you ever do a Twitter space?
Went off stream. I don't like Twitter spaces. Twitter is for opening up,
using one handed and then closing again. That's why I never use the damn thing. Although if you
do follow me on Twitter, you might have seen the fucking cringy memes I made of the girls,
okay? I said what I said. I said what I said. I made memes of the girls. I said memes of the girls.
I made memes of them before I knew them and I posted them. So if you do want to go on my Twitter,
it is linked in the description below, but I don't really use it that much outside of that
cringy fire. The Aminia Zero memes were on point. Yeah, so I didn't know the girls when I made them.
We didn't know their personalities or anything. So thank you for the stream. Anytime spent always
makes my day better. No, thank you. The big step one has to be the best one. Okay, I'm going to
give you loads of kisses. Thank you for letting me play this game with you for the first time. I
thoroughly enjoyed that. That's 10 out of 10 experience. That was lovely. Absolutely lovely.
And I will see you tomorrow at the regular Schmaggler time, okay? Not to be confused with Schmaggler.
Regular Schmaggler time. I'll see you. It'll be that soon. Experience tomorrow. So please
do it. If you're expecting me, be like surprise. No, I'm just I'm ranting in the void, ranting
about any subject that I like and what's meant to me, okay? Stronny standard time. Exactly. Stronny
standard time. No puking. Sheeby's got you. Azura's got you. Azura's up with a Apollo right now.
No, thank you. And Keanu Reeves points. Okay, I'll give you loads of kisses. Thank you. I see you
tomorrow and you never know. I might just have a new ASMR video up as well as Mercy. Thank you,
Reefling. Love you. Say hi to Sheeby for me.